[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the St Louis super Swiss
great to be back here with some more
games if you guys remember before we
went on to the break we were
looking at one of the local favorites
Grandmaster version akobian
that seems to have been out prepared a
little bit by his young Grandmaster
opponent Balaji dagupati but certainly
it showed us a very interesting line in
the exchange
slav and I think they're quite a lot of
other games that are interesting today
some people were asking in the chat
about the Aram
game against Fidel Corrales would you
like us yeah let's go back to that game
we spent quite a bit of time on it
earlier wow it's an end game right now
and someone in the chat is saying that
Iran blundered it back to a quality okay
and they were talking about the move
Knight F6 so let's go to this was the
this was a moment where we kind of
stopped here and we're thinking about
Bishop takes uh as being the move that
had to be played in this position we
thought but we couldn't we couldn't come
up with a way for white to take the
control in the position right maybe we
should turn on the engine here to see if
they should take Z4 to move
um yeah and Knight F6 is the move for
now it takes E4 is also
a little better 94.
okay so I was thinking ig5 but I guess
Knight D4 with the idea of maybe having
some C6 going
in a way but since that Knight F6 is
always the kind of move that black man
it's interesting here where I said that
if you move the Knight Queen H4 check I
said that before would be potentially a
problem and the computer comes down
after King to D1 it sort of settles back
to a quality effort thanks for a little
while here although it's it's
complicated
it is it is the kind of move that you
don't think you're going to play but um
the king is fine in the center you know
um so now it's settling on whites a
little bit better here so yeah this is a
very complicated position we should turn
the engine back off so we're not
cheating here
but it said uh what I was able to see as
I turned it off is that in this position
Knight F6 was a correct move by by black
that seemed to be either that or
or yeah that was the main one that the
the engine was suggesting and it might
if you play E5 here
you have 94.
and now if the Queens get traded black
will be happy because he does have some
pressure on these spawns King takes and
then the king can choose whether it's
gonna go probably is going to go there
it will not choose anything C8 or C7 the
king should be safe whereas wise pawns
want
there's also ideas with 97 to get the C5
Pawn so I think
um
yeah it's still interesting because you
know Black's a little soft on F7
um so you can probably cast along with
Czech here and
put the King on C2 maybe but long-term
black has chances here I agree it
actually seems a little bit how are you
going to be able to protect both of
these threats at this moment
yes it's going to be difficult I think
for for white to kind of cover both but
okay so E5 was not the move chosen by by
Fidel he ended up going Knight D4
so still putting some pressure over here
potentially having some sacrifice ideas
and certainly C6 is going to be an
annoying kind of idea that black has to
figure out how to deal with and Aram
decided to deal with that move by
placing his Knight to C6
okay because obviously you don't want to
trade
here I guess but
I do not know why that can be forced
because after Knight C6 after Knight
takes C6 then
well now now he takes and he's happy for
the right and then if you go E5 to 1995
attacking these two pawns right for
about F6 this one is hanging as well so
I think black is doing quite well in
this position
but um okay if we don't have
that and we trade first don't we get to
take the spawn in E4
was he worried about the capturing B5
and then if you take back Knight takes
B5 and he was worried about being able
to meet Knight C7 and then
maybe thinking that this Pawn would be
yeah again this this position is quite
double-edged there
but after a takes B5 Black's not forced
to recapture the pawn and um
maybe Knight takes C3
there's Bishop takes C4 is an optional
though maybe maybe black would capture
in G2 as well
yeah it's a it's a very complicated
position it is it's
it's bored and there are captures that
have to be considered no wonder the
players have spent have started spending
some time
um
Fidel has already spent about four more
than 40 minutes and then Aram started
spending more time in this position as
well
he played Knight C6 after 10 10 11
minutes of thought
and I guess Queen takes C8
so Fidel did not allow for the cap the
capture to happen because we've seen
that position yeah right
Rook takes and now Knight takes B5 this
is a very interesting choice from White
so he's basically giving up the peace
temporary as he thinks he's two pawns
connected
here are going to be
making more than enough for the piece as
you know C6 is approaching next move
probably getting it back
and why to match with the bishop air
and with this Pawn to be captured very
soon
I like this sacrifice Knight takes E4
okay so black does not want to move the
Knight let's just say Knight here for
example or where would you where would
you move in Knight A7 I I think they're
all dangerous at this point because
normally in these types of positions if
you have the two pawns side by side on
the fifth rank you have enough for the
piece Unless somehow black can force you
to move the pawns forward and black can
get a blockade in these types of
positions and I don't see how black gets
a blockade if he moves the Knight
because if you go to A7 can't I just
take the pawn on C4 with my Bishop
so I guarded the pond
and I was thinking C6 but yeah well and
I I I can maybe play C6 shortly
when I was trying to figure out how I
could get my two Bishops into the game
because because
yeah
one of these captures is going to happen
maybe Knight takes you somehow have to
play C6 eventually
and the thing is that I do want to keep
one of my Bishops I would probably
I don't know if I'm really forced to
give up the piece back but I will
let's look at this position what do we
think about it
and maybe this bishop to B4 here to to
hang on to my Pawn but but Black's
probably Black's okay here
I feel confident about Black's position
here this one will be hanging
potentially as well but um I think
someone in the chat was asking us about
Rook takes D.A or kimchi C8
if black had played King tasty was that
an option I did not consider that move
what about night
night takes here probably not an option
but King takes that's an interesting
approach try to bring the king to block
those potentially arising two past pawns
if white were considering to still take
but isn't a potential long Castle an
option for right here
well also
you know
I'm trying to see whether a takes B5
makes any sense here it may not because
White's always going to get the E4 Pawn
here I'm a little bit worried about
remaining pinned on the file that's why
I don't want to do that right
but it is certainly an option takes
takes Knight takes nobody is going to
make me move this bishop anytime soon so
that's
a threat for white well and I'm not
again sure that black Caster recapture
on B5 oh you're right they keep taking
it back right so I'm not so sure that
you can't
move the night do you even take and take
on e4 I mean you're allowing past pawns
that looks a little risky but
um
I think that would be too rich yeah it
seems like it's too much
although maybe just take States and now
takes B5 and then I'm going to try and
take on e4 yeah
because now this bishop pair
is going to be restricted by the pawns
and black has two two connected past
pawns too what do you think I I don't
know that's why I was looking at this
and again I can't come to a clear
evaluation here because you know White's
going to get a blockade on B4 although
maybe not they're quick because that
rook's pinned so if you look at this
Knight takes e takes eight takes B5 and
there's an immediate threat of um B4
to move the pawns forward some lines and
then
um you know if you play Bishop takes E4
all of a sudden the white pawns on D4
and C5 are blockaded and whereas the
black pawns can't be easily blockaded
after Bishop takes E4 and 19. right this
looks really dangerous looking good B4
and C3 and this bishop could be
potentially restricted in A1 when you go
Bishop B2 so this could have been an
interesting choice for black I mean
white does not need to go for that line
necessarily obviously we're just trying
on things here
something I would love to do but it's
not really feasible is get the chance to
somehow take and play Bishop before but
unfortunately this Pawn will be hanging
so my check here is not gonna do much
and the great thing for black is that
his Rook is protected by the bishop
which means any captures in B5 will not
lead to not allowing black to have you
know connected pawns because black can
always recapture and their Rook will
always always be protected so I think
this is a choice is a great game for the
readers to analyze with a computer at
home because there's such an interesting
Dynamic here on attacking what appear to
be potentially weak pawns on the queen
side for black but it could potentially
become strong and with the various
hanging pawns it's a fascinating
position that you know we're not going
to be able to do it justice talking
about it without looking at it with the
machine to be quite honest because it's
it's just too complicated
and for for some some people who want to
get in some training it's always nice to
get complicated positions like this and
then get to play them against
someone of a similar strength and that's
that's another great way that you can
kind of train your
um or or improve your understanding in
some positions when you get to play them
with both colors and it doesn't have to
be like super fast time controls it
could be 10 15 minute games and
um
uh that could be that could be this
could be a great great example sometimes
people are having a hard time finding
things
um to play but yeah moving that Rook
from the a file was an interesting
choice that uh thanks for pointing it
out who is it but Patrick I think if I'm
reading his name right yes pointed it
out on the YouTube chat thanks for that
Patrick certainly an interesting idea
there for black to keep the Rook on the
file and make it difficult for white now
Knight takes B5 was the option that
Fidel chose and the current position if
we can catch up
with it is here
after Bishop takes
Bishop B4
so that's that was the move
that Fidel played and how do we evaluate
this position white has the bishop pair
material is at the moment equal but
black is about to lose that pawn
or that's the threat at least in this
position okay so I guess he chose to
give it up and somehow
probably Aram has in mind this move
Knight to D2 after Bishop takes and
trying to chase the bishop
while attacking the pawn in G2 so maybe
that's why he's not worried
how would you assess this position I I
think it's still very double-edged
because as you point out if you play
Bishop take C4 Knight D2 if you know
black gets the pawn on G2 White's going
to be perpetually stuck with the weak H2
and F4 Pawns in return for having a pass
Pawn in the bishop pair
and and the these types of fights fight
around whether or not white can control
the squares in front of his past C5 Pawn
if white can control those squares to to
advance the C5 Pawn that pawns very
strong and it's a winning asset and if
black can maintain control of C6 black
is fine that's what the fight really
revolves around
and normally the bishop here is
effective in these wide open positions
where there's not a lot of Center pawns
but the black has piece activity here
again I wouldn't be shocked if the
computer says this is close to equal but
but it also wouldn't shock me if it says
that White's better here
but I I don't know it's we'll have to
wait and see how the the Grandmasters
choose to play this this position
um
right we should look at some other games
we've spent a lot of time with a highly
interesting position we already seem to
have a result actually on board nine
Aaron grabinski one he's game against
Talia Cervantes another
favorite here at the club I don't know
if you want to check that game yeah
absolutely
see what happened in that game that was
quite fast so I I have a long history
with both of these players I've played
both of them many many times in my life
and um
tally has been living here in St Louis
for probably the last eight years or so
and vastly improved in her chess game in
the last couple years yes she's she's
been doing amazing I've seen her very
dedicated to improving a first
I think one of my first times being a
Grandmaster in Residence she challenged
me to some to play some games training
games the first first time I think it
was easy but after that it wasn't easy
anymore and then I started I started
getting to play with her over the board
in classical chess and
yeah I lost I lost some games
so Knight D5 was played I don't know if
this move being I think even Queen D3 or
Talia has played an interesting move
order here
or maybe Aaron has played an interesting
move order yeah
and I think she was trying to transpose
into a Nodge door yeah
but that didn't happen since his Queen
capture so that that would have been
somehow Knight F6 and then try to get to
play well depends what like what white
plays obviously if Bishop G5 or Bishop
C4 will not go for E5 line I have to
stick to E6
but
um okay so he went Queen takes D4 some
kind of
not exactly
I don't think that's the name in this
variation
the human back Queen D3 and typically
you wouldn't
it's gonna it's kind of tricky when you
take with the queen I think for white
because you don't really have a good
placement for the queen that's not gonna
bother one of your Bishops so you have
to to choose one of the
one of the least bad decisions in a way
but one popular line recently has been
to put the queen on D2 and play B3
Bishop B2 and Castle long and I don't
think that position arises directly in
this position it normally comes after
Queen takes D4 on move four instead of
move five and I couldn't tell you what
the differences are but it but it arises
and then B3 and Bishop B2 but but the
white still has to deal with this so
Bishop D3 would be the way to deal with
the I am not an expert in this line in
any way shape or form I would think
Knight C3 would be the move but again I
am not an expert yeah I thought maybe
white could try to to wait a little bit
and just go Bishop D3 so that uh maybe
even C4 could be a move that the white
place which typically they don't get in
in a lot of Sicilians because they have
to develop the Knight to protect the
pawn this not being an right but that's
a that's a different idea yeah entirely
yeah yeah but I like that it's it's
quite an interesting idea to to fianca
to the bishop which we typically end up
seeing in E3 or G5 in most descendants
so they played they're probably both
somewhat out of theory here 95 is an
interesting move yeah I'm guessing Aaron
probably looked at this before the game
you know because it's just not a series
of moves Queen D3 and Knight D5 that you
come up with um at the board
and Aaron is also a player that plays
really quickly he puts a lot of pressure
on his opponents by playing very very
fast
some people are saying that they
they're still going on
okay I don't know I
we are we're looking into it we'll we'll
let you guys know
about it so let's see so Queen takes F6
C3
Bishop E7 Bishop E2 okay so very normal
development C3 was necessary here in
order to be able to develop this bishop
Bishop B2 Queen G6
castle and now Talia went for E5 to open
up her bishop and go for ideas of Bishop
H3 most likely
and Aaron went for Knight D2 that's a
nice idea of opening up the queen
to avoid those kind of ideas but maybe
prepare for potential F4 huh F4 maybe a
little weakening here because you're
going to have the isolated Pawn on e4
and I'm not sure White's pieces are
ready to attack okay then maybe just
this maybe just Knight C4 no we'll get
rid of that line maybe Knight C4
putting some pressure yeah or Knight C4
and putting pressure on Black's Queen
side and Center
so F5 was played Bishop F3
okay Castle takes takes
that check seems natural
although
and here for the queen trade which she
refused
who is better in this end game and how
do we recapture of course typically we
take towards the center
but is this an option as well F takes G3
here
I think white wants to play this
position slowly and take with the H Pawn
because white is behind in development
I would take with this this spawn as
well I thought maybe that could be an
option too and would you where would you
place this night would you put it in
yeah I like white in this position a lot
because the piece placement I think is
pretty easy here the the Black Knight on
C6 is not well placed because of the
Pawn on C3 and white can put his Knight
on e4 put his Bishop on E3 and and then
I think white is ready to
um Advance on the queen side with you
know his pawns to you know try and
you know put some pressure over there
I I think that you know in this type of
position you can play for B4 A4 B5
and see if you can make inroads over
there
I I agree with you I would probably put
my my Rook on D1 first and then
um considered the marching of the pawns
as well
um I would probably keep my pony C3 for
a little bit longer just to make sure
yeah I don't want to ever push the C
Pawn when I'm trying to accomplish here
is I want to see if I can
um
you know invade on the a file and you
know that Bishop on D5 is putting
pressure on the B7 Pawn there and if I
can win it
I I mean I'm going to win the game yes
yes
um but okay so
um
Talia decided not to go for the trade
she went for Queen H5 and then Knight to
C4
was played by Aaron Rook F6 Queen G5 and
why would this game why would do we have
a result we have not been told anything
just yet
yeah
yeah that that seems wrong here it seems
wrong you would have resigned in this
position yeah
I mean I think there's still play I mean
I I think white plays
is there a way to trap the queen no
Bishop E3 but you know you got to look
at Rook to G6 right away yeah there's
some tricks here yeah she has some
pressure
um yeah the game is still going on so we
just have the result okay that's we just
saw move all right so either either the
game has finished and there's always
placed and they're inputting the moves
manually which is probably not what is
going on but we just saw a move so yeah
yeah I think the result is wrong I think
this position still pretty double-edged
I think black needs to keep the Queens
on because like I said you know white is
behind in development so if you trade
Queens you can slow play the position I
think as I was suggesting on the queen
side but with the Queens on you know
black and double Rooks on the f file and
there there's lots of different things
that black can try and do to to
strengthen her position and she can also
have some ideas with Bishop G5 at some
point with the Rook staying on the sixth
rank this Pawn being protected she might
might be able to go Bishop G5 and trade
that Bishop but not too soon because
white hasn't taken it out so there's no
need to rush to get rid of that Bishop
that hasn't been played so probably just
an error in the in the showing of the
result which I'm sure is going to be
fixed shortly and Patrick is asking I
think back in that end game the pieces
don't get out fast enough because the F5
Bishop is hanging if I take with the F
Pawn and you know I I guess I'm a little
bit low this white in that end game we
were looking at yes this one to because
Black's work's already on the f file so
the bishop on F5 isn't hanging and I I
am giving black a pass Pawn there albeit
it's very securely blockaded but I I'm
just thinking that with my Pawn on F2 I
got all the time in the world in this
position to improve my position as white
and I have less time I think to improve
it if I you know have the pawns on H2 G2
and G3
so I I think when you're behind in
development you want to think about okay
can I slow play the position and slowly
improve whereas if you're
you know behind development you don't
want to play a move that forces you to
play faster and I think that taking with
the H Pawn allows you to play the
position slower as white when you're
behind in development yeah
and and it's actually quite interesting
as as uh you're discussing this position
so another move was played and so Aaron
went for the queen trade again and Talia
returned she does not want to trade she
has no one to get into that ending and
she doesn't seem to have an escape since
you know white is going to follow up
with him she doesn't want to draw either
she does not want to draw which is
interesting maybe she's got a good uh a
good result against her her
um opponent to Aaron grabinski so maybe
she's just she's trying to push further
um
and um and and she just retreated now
and she's
she cannot do that just yet I'm not sure
how what her follow-up is going to be
she has ideas with Bishop D3 potentially
and then moving The Rook with some
Discovery even Rook takes F2 would be an
option so now
white has to move the queen again most
likely
she's a huge Fighter um I I think she's
taking a risk here but you know as we
said before the tournament with the
rating disparity you get these types of
fights that you may not get between the
very highest rated players playing each
other I mean this is a position as black
I I would probably be happy to to repeat
there and maybe that's because I'm not
as big a fighter as Talia but I I I
guess my concern would be here is that
Rook on A8 is now out of play
um you have Knight B6 potentially coming
in and some lines in the bishop to E3
and you haven't helped your your
position here
it's it's going to be concrete for a few
more moves if white manages to get the
bishop out I think white is going to
have a better position but if he doesn't
manage to coordinate his pieces to avoid
these kind of potential sacrifices I
think black eventually will get that
Queen somehow back into the game right
but what concerns me about Black's
position is at night on C6 really has
nowhere to go in the foreseeable future
the the bishop on E7 really isn't that
aggressively placed and it's going to be
hard to get it aggressively placed and
then you know the Rook on F6 is guarding
the bishop on F5 so the the black pieces
aren't exactly jumping into the game
immediately so white white can improve
and Black's got to sort of untangle
that's right but well that remains to be
seen shall we go to another game do we
have any requests at the moment or why
don't we look at Dennis boros's game on
on the next board board eight
Ana Maria Mariano Dennis borders he's
another local here in San Luis many
times GM res
yeah Dennis is a very funny guy he's a
lot of fun to hang around he's a player
that I've also played many times in
tournament games yeah you know living
here and
um it's very interesting he's somewhat
lower rated than some of the players
over at Webster but having spent some
time over there when they play rapid
events Dennis generally wins all of them
even against the much higher rated
players but then in the classical chess
maybe his results aren't quite as good
but he's a natural attacking player and
in Rapid he's extremely strong and he
has very good results against much
higher rated players
um I I have a nice
have had good results with Dennis over
the years I mean that are
disproportionate to our ratings because
he's a much better player than I am but
he plays interesting chess and sometimes
when you're you're meeting you're
getting the chance to play an aggressive
player and it's always there's always
going to be interesting games I think as
even when you think you finally have a
good positional game and everything is
fine and you should be winning suddenly
out of nowhere that's typically what
happens with me with when I play even
like with my dad sometimes you know he I
think I finally got him in some benoni
and I have white pieces of course and
then he out of nowhere comes up with
this tactic that I should have known all
these years but apparently I don't and
then yeah it's um I I had one game
against them where basically all the
pieces were hanging and I thought that I
was just dead lost and he made a move
and he offered me a draw and of course I
accepted it and he thought he was dead
lost because all of his pieces were
hanging as well and we put into the
computer afterwards and of course it was
zero zero zero oh my goodness okay we've
all had pieces hanging everywhere and it
was just a mess and neither of us knew
what was going on it was very funny I've
played this line as white before here I
I was an English player
um these are double-edged positions this
is you know potentially dangerous for
white but also white has some positional
trumps
yeah you're you're basically getting a
reverse um Dragon of Sicilian with the
white pieces and that extra tempo
which in this case might be the the
movie three could or could not be
helpful
um the weak Pawn on D3 which you may be
able to push D4 yeah so so you are going
to try to find a way to get D4 in I
think and um and then typically I think
you would want to take with a piece but
oftentimes people kind of have to take
with the pawn and then white will remain
with an isolated Pawn here and with a
lot of pieces being traded it might turn
out to be a weakness
but let's see how Anna Maria has decided
to continue here so she did go for D4
and took with the pawn right you have to
get your pieces into play as well here
this bishop needs to be developed so
rookie one nice move to Temple as long
as nothing is lost it which doesn't seem
like it will be
Bishop back to E3 now I don't know if
that's a move I would want to make here
with white
I I wonder how aggressive a move like H4
would be
it's pretty aggressive because that pawn
on G3 is weaker and the bishop is
bearing down on F2 if you can ever
liquidate the D4 upon
I agree I just have a very concrete
threat right now and possibly like is
let's just say you make this mistake I
think it's a mistake it better I better
show something just just for the
audience and there's a piece hanging and
there's a queen that's
I don't know I don't know I was gonna
say something this but
I'm even correct If This Were to be a
line because out of nowhere out of
nowhere this queen is very unpleasantly
agreed I don't know if my my line was
certainly no it's an interesting idea my
good friend Sam Shanklin was playing an
Armageddon tournament in Berlin and he
lost the last round to Wesley so and he
basically got checkmated in the last
round game with exactly configuration
where white um I did not see that traded
the bishop on G2 for a piece on D5 and
Wesley's Queen was on F5 and he was able
to play his Queen to H3 with check and
then Bishop takes D5 and you Sam had to
put a rook on F3 too yeah and that was
it yeah but I mean so yeah this is
dangerous this type of situation for
white
but it is dangerous so H4 is definitely
a weakening move here although it does
seem like it will create some
unpleasantries it's more for white so
you cannot really do that so maybe
bishop E3 does have similar ideas now
just keeps the position a little bit
more more safe
um yeah but you're you're giving up that
bishop and when you take back with the F
Pawn you have this sort of long-term
hanging Pawn
situation but you don't have a black
squared bishop and again white can't
move those pawns without creating a
serious weakness
yes that's that's the problem and
unfortunately for white she cannot
capture in B6 in between move because
Knight C2 seems to be losing an exchange
in that position so
uh Danish first played A4 right to kick
the Queen off the B6 position and then
to actually that's that's a nice move
but that also creates potentially a
weakness talking about Sam Sam shranklin
has two very famously known books small
steps to Giant Improvement I always
recommend that book
um he doesn't know this but like a few
actually in 2018 I believe he he um he
wrote that book and I was having a
terrible U.S championship and before the
last round I was
um I was really struggling and I was
playing against any Bank who was leading
the tournament at the time and I don't
think I've ever said this story live but
um I was very sad and trying to look for
some YouTube chess videos to kind of get
some motivation going and I found his um
some some shanklin's video on on YouTube
here at the club he was talking about
the book and he was talking about the
hook when you're pushing you know this
this age Pawn in some situations it
could create a weakness around your king
and I was inspired by by that video with
these ideas of playing G4 G5 and some
qgd and I ended up playing this line it
was totally wrong but my phone played H6
quite early and Annie was supposed to
win the US championship at the time but
my idea turned out to be really great
and every time I was seeing a pom push I
was thinking about Sam's lecture that I
watched online it wasn't live or
anything but it's it is still on
sandwiches club's YouTube channel so if
you if you don't follow the club's
YouTube channel yet I know you're here
but if you don't follow the Channel
please do so and check out some of the
game some of the YouTube's uh lots of
very interesting material but I wasn't
told to say this so this is just my
story by the way and uh and yeah I won
the game and unfortunately for any she
did not become
championed that year but but I was kind
of proud of that game because I made
long castle and it was totally wrong in
a Queen's Gambit to take us along but I
think it worked if you're the Grand
Master in this position you're pretty
happy as black here because you've
created an imbalance in the position I
think she took with the F Bond she did
she did and then Bishop E6 but okay if
he does get the bishop in B3 could get a
little bit annoying Maybe
but he
Queen D3 okay yeah yeah and it's not
easy to get to the white pawns but this
is one of those positions where it's
very difficult for white to advance
those pawns because of the weaknesses
they create coming behind and black has
time to sort of
slowly improve the position here I mean
but you will struggle however to protect
this sponsor you might always have to
stay with the piece to keep it protected
maybe bishop B3 but that's going to take
your Bishop from some other
things that he could do just to keep it
protected because B5 is definitely not
going to be something to be considering
by black right I don't want to put my
Bishop on B3 but black can play Bishop
C7 and black can maybe kick the Knight
out with F6 and bring a rook over to E8
and then play H5 H4 I mean those are all
okay black can do and and white okay
when you look at this position you know
white can kick the queen around with you
know Knight F3 and and maybe try and
repeat but what is White gonna do to
improve here I was thinking King H1 and
then getting the Rook on the file the
problem is you know as I was thinking
that I realized that Bishop in B3 will
be very annoying for that to happen and
then if I put the rook in D2 then Bishop
A5 is going to be even more annoying
you know the power of the bishop pair if
you didn't realize how they work they
work on diagonals next to each other in
a way oftentimes and right it creates
these but I mean very difficult position
white um you know say doubles on the f
file because that's the openf file and
black just says okay I'm going to play
F6 and kick your knight away
um maybe it's not very aggressive but
then what do you do as white to to
improve this this is what I wanted to do
that's why I was putting my king in H1
to avoid staying on the you know staying
pinned over here but it just seems very
difficult to do for white right attack
and when you do that when you play E4 D5
and I've played H5 H4 to soften up your
g-pawn that's because your King's over
on the H file I understand I understand
I mean maybe I will have to play H4 King
H2 in that case if that's even a
possibility because
okay if I have the pawn question E4 then
of course my queen protects G3
but it's it's not going to I I I played
this one he will be weak too though yeah
I've played these positions a lot as
white and I I was very happy playing
these because they were double edged for
a long time and I guess the longer I
played them the more I realized that the
the bishop pairs extremely annoying here
and I think over the long term that
black has very good chances because the
the white king is exposed in the long
term not in the near term
but in the long term
I'm curious what the engine says here
just out of curiosity you know there was
a position like this but it wasn't quite
like this but there's a
Trojan game where the pawns were not
this Pawn structure here was the same
but you know what he did
he did the King march there's a game I
don't remember against whom it is but
there's a game someone who knows can
give it a search
where I believe this Paul was in D2 it
was on this side of the board the pawn
structure was a little bit different and
he got some attack going actually white
got some attack going but um you cannot
do this
I'm curious what the engine says here
just out of curiosity it's probably much
better for black
minus 1.7 yeah yeah White's just loose
over there so okay that doesn't shock me
that it's minus 1.7 for black here
yeah this this last move makes it
difficult for white to to do things now
you have to do something about the
Knight because that's direct threat
right now and
um like we already mentioned Rook D1
does not work in the chat Patrick is
saying white has to play E4 D5 isn't
that the only plan and yes Patrick I
agree it's the only plan but you know as
you can see here my comment about the
white king being loose and it appears
that stockfish
um is agreeing that black is just just
better here maybe because White's too
loose certainly a better position but
but it's an interesting game and it's an
interesting position
um sure
looks like a fairly balance so the white
has two Bishops there so they played uh
closed Catalan
or
okay
Queen C1 no display by elshon Bishop E7
Castle
okay so this is uh I think they're
they're uh still following
they're still following actually it's a
Sam Shanklin game with black with white
was done it'll do both
six six was played in that game
Bishop F4
white has to improve the special portals
you know it's going to be difficult to
develop the Knight and also now after C6
that diagonal opens up the bishop is in
E7 but he couldn't have put it in D6
because of potential C5
so
we see these ideas quite often 95
interesting
interesting choice
to play 95 in this moment as soon as B6
was played because you're playing the
movie Tempo but
um I guess Alison is not worried about a
potential capture because he would take
back with the pawn right yeah but he
wants the bishop here so he's played 95
to take on D5 and play Knight C6 and
grab the bishop here this is a known
position
here and again I I've actually had this
position in correspondence game I think
it's in one of the average books and he
claims that white is better here what do
you think uh having played it in a
correspondence game at zero zero zero
but it again it takes accurate play and
it's it's interesting from both sides
because black has the possibility of
getting into
um
you know the queen side because Black's
more active in return for giving up the
bishop pair
so it's an interesting position but if
you put it into a computer it'll tell
you that it's it's equal
so that was the game I was thinking of
Patrick's Patrick was
Patrick was uh
Patrick was
okay okay Patrick was was saying that
Patricia on Seeker I think it was that
that was the game I was talking about
the treasurement it sounds sounds
familiar so I think that was the one
yes there's a King march did you did you
check that game do you do you like it
hopefully you do
um
there are some other King march games I
love the King march
it's just because it's so out of out of
control you don't expect something like
that to happen you think you know
you should do something faster but no
you're first bringing the king to safety
so Rook seed and I think in my game I
played Queen A4 that I was referring to
but this is normal the reason I put the
queen on A4 is because it saves a Tempo
when you know black plays Knight E8 and
then Knight C7 I see okay because that
that's gonna be where's the night going
um you try to expand on the queen side
with B5 B4 and then the knights can come
in on the queen side so probably you
won't be able to take this Pawn for some
reason hey you don't you don't have to
expand right away yeah okay it's got
time but anyway but I was trying to play
Queen B5 I mean again as a position that
can be played slowly because it's closed
white has the bishop pair and he's
holding on to it obviously the trade
would actually help black bring the
Knight to a much better location
um and queen back to D3
uh probably getting out of Harm's Way
because this seems to be the next move
that black is going to play to bring the
Knight yep
95.
so technically
this is not possible right because
Knight takes D6 in between
okay so we'll we'll look at this game in
a result before we take a break here so
we'll go relatively quickly here so we
can do that we have we have a result
Brandon Jacobson did win his game
against Costa kavitsky or just told so
we'll get to that game uh in a in a
moment and we'll show you that game as
soon as possible right let's just flip
through the moves here yeah yeah real
quick to see whether or not because I I
I I'll let you guide this you you have
the role you have you
I think these positions are very
interesting I I think that the with the
Queens off this tends to favor white a
little bit more but again you can see
how black gained the C file he did but
look at these Bishops once they spawn a
star marching forward these Bishops are
going to be very unpleasant this is uh
this is a I love the idea of retreating
them first and those knives don't have
outposts just yet so oh
he grabbed it is that oh you can get
away with it too okay okay so elsin one
upon
is he gonna be able to hold on to it is
the question
because this this is going to be Black's
next move trying to get it back
no there's also a back rank problems the
white has but I don't think this is a
move that I don't think you want to play
this to give that Knight
that square I don't think so but I could
be wrong
right and you can also play Rook to um
to A3 to guard it but I black might
still be within the drawing margin here
but White's probably pushing a little
bit here
okay and their times are about the same
so
all right let's uh let's check out that
game Brandon Jacobson against uh what
we don't have the game we only have two
moves
question did not show up and the game
ended after how much time was it two
hours and a half yeah yeah right we
don't see the movie we don't see the
reasons why I didn't go to it oh okay I
thought you said I thought you said to
catch up so yeah
well we'll take a break and see if we
can cure that technical difficulty on
break that is fine hopefully and we'll
also see if we can get some interviews
while we're on break here as well yes if
we have some interviews that would be
amazing uh
anyways guys thank you so much for
staying with us we'll be back shortly
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March for the second
annual American Cup world-class Chess
Masters will gather in the chest capital
of America St Louis Missouri to compete
in a double elimination tournament for a
combined 300 000 in prizes we will cover
all the action live from the World Chess
Hall of Fame from March 17th through
March 26th tune in for the best game in
chess streaming live for more
information visit uschesschamps.com
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March for the second
annual American Cup world-class Chess
Masters will gather in the chest capital
of America St Louis Missouri to compete
in a double elimination tournament for a
combined 300 000 in prizes we will cover
all the action live from the World Chess
Hall of Fame from March 17th through
March 26th tune in for the best game in
chess streaming live for more
information visit uschesschamps.com
the St Louis chess club's 2023 chess
season launches in March for the second
annual American Cup world-class Chess
Masters will gather in the chest capital
of America St Louis Missouri to compete
in a double elimination tournament for a
combined three hundred thousand dollars
in prizes we will cover all the action
live from the World Chess Hall of Fame
from March 17th through March 26th tune
in for the best game in chess streaming
live for more information visit
uschesschamps.com
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to round three of the San
Luis super Swiss event before the break
we made this big announcement that there
was a result in the game between Brandon
Jacobson and Costa kabutsky
however
however we don't have the game just yet
and as you're waiting for that and for a
potential interview I suggest to go back
if you agree
Doug to go back to this game because
wow there was a castle
everybody's calling for us to look at
this game where did we left it off we
left it off around here
here somewhere oh wait yes here
I think we're yeah we were right here in
1994 and white had guarded the pawn on
C3 and C5 with Bishop B4 I think because
when we last looked at them yes we
stopped around here I think and and
black had castled and we were waiting to
see if white was going to capture this
Pawn which seems like Fidel did
interesting because I think I thought
that um black would claim Knight to D2
yeah yeah that's that was our final
assessment and hitting the uh the pawn
on G2 and the bishop is this an option
is this the reason why black would have
decided not to go for this move
as possible everything in chess is
concrete but that seems surprising
because that doesn't seem all that
threatening because how do you get your
pieces out here I mean
um yeah
I was thinking we could probably even
take and then we have well you could put
your Rook on D2 here or D2 even worse
and I don't know
I know this this looks really bad this
looks really bad but instead Aram chose
to put the rooking D2 directly
thinking that is going to be even better
but this bishop is not I mean maybe
there was another move after 92 not
Bishop F1
but what could that move be
just Bishop E2 and then after you take
just something like this or
well Mr Bishop B2 Bishop takes and Rook
to G1 I I don't see
anything great here for for white I mean
if anything else I mean I can check and
go into The Bishop's opposite color
ending and I can't imagine that I've got
any problems here it's black and I've
got two weaknesses to work on forever
we'll get back to this game in just a
moment and see how it seems like uh
Fidel has won his game but we are told
we have the interview ready for you guys
um between uh Jacob Sanders and
Brandon Jacobson let's pull it up
I am here with Grand Master Brandon
Jacobson fresh off his win against
International Master kostia kavitsky
Brandon you know take me through all of
the life of how it is to win a chess
game I wouldn't know nothing about it of
course of course okay so apparently the
GT were broke so I'll have to make the
moves myself
um yeah so I had to try E4 against me
actually beat me in
um a few months ago when I played that
F3 in G3 so I didn't want to repeat that
I want to play something more ambitious
against him um so after this Ross limo
he went for G6 Castle Bishop G7 or q1
all pretty standard then F6 yeah here I
found this interesting try to go H3 and
D3 and
the idea in these positions is it's
really kind of difficult to
continue for black because the general
plans are okay you want to bring your
net around to E6 somehow either through
like D7 and f8 or through E8 and C7
um but I'm sort of playing a bunch of
waiting moves to see how black commits
to setting up his pieces before I push
E5 shutting out his bishop and it's not
actually so simple for black to continue
so he played B6 very logical just
um keeping control C5 A4 A5 and now net
A3
and yeah I think this is already quite
tricky for black because okay I'm gonna
put that on C4 b62 is going to be weak
and here you put a logical moves 98 but
I think this is already a step in the
wrong direction
um it felt to me like the more precise
way of playing was to go Queen C7
and the point is that he wants to wait
and for E5 to put his name on D5 now and
now B6 pretty well covered and you can
sort of continue not logically with like
Bishop A6 or whatever and it's kind of
tricky for white to improve here I was
probably by something like Bishop D2
cardio Queen C1 and Bishop H6 but you
know the game goes on here with d8
because the way you put in the game
um after 98 now for E5 the problem for
him is that b62 is going to be a
weakness and if I tried to play it in a
similar way after Queen C7 and when
Knight C4 now I think he's in time to go
Knight D7
and the key Point here is that okay if I
do nothing he's gonna go E5 himself next
move and if I go E5 he's in time for B5
now E5 is hanging so that's why I think
it was pretty important for him to play
accurately here because after 98 E5 ic7
Knight C4 Knight E6
Bishop T2 we get this position which
looks reasonable for black but it's kind
of difficult for him to move because I'm
just in time to stop E5 now A5 is
hanging and I have a simple plan of
going Queen C1 and Bishop H6
and I think already here he needs to
realize that things are sort of going
out of hand he needs to strike with F5
and the reason I think this is clever
here is because I don't really have to
tell you Queen C1 because now he shuts
me out with that with F4 so I kind of
have to take I have six year and then
play something simple like Bishop C3
and probably yeah white white slightly
better here B6 is a week my pieces are
pretty active but the game goes on like
you can play something like Rook A7
maybe with ideas either rookie seven or
if D4 then you can take everything and
Rook D7 at the right moment
and yeah I mean although it should be
slightly better I mean like it's kind of
hard for me to for me to prove my pieces
here still so I think
black still sort of fighting here
um he played Knight D4 which oh sorry
sorry played hrx first
which okay his idea was out of Queen two
I know he wants to meet with King H7 and
uh let me trade darks for Bishops
but I think this doesn't really work
here because after rookie for
the problem firm is that like he can't
really
control
all these squares that I'm attacking
because like
and a lot of in a lot of lines like the
queen would love to like join the
defense now like there are a lot of
lines where he would go Queenie 8 and F5
and he can never do that because B6 is
always weak and
already here let's say he plays sort of
a waiting move like King H7 and I play
Queen C1
um it's actually very difficult for my
ready like he can't go Knight D4 now
because I have a strick would take take
Bishop takes H6
and if he plays any other move I mean my
next move is going to be Rec H4 H5 and
G4 just sort of crashing through so he
kind of needs to do something
immediately and if he plays F5 now well
I'm a lot better prepared for it because
I can go Queenie two and he doesn't
really have a way of
keeping my pieces out of the e-file so
yeah he went for Knight before now but
then I found this clever idea I think
after take take playing Rook H4
and the problem does he just can't
defend all his weaknesses
um again he can't go King H7 because
it's a strict with Queen 22 and the
point is I'm just trying to promote
weaknesses like you need to either make
a committed decision we're going G5 or
H5 and whichever one is going to have
for drawbacks like let's say you put H5
then after Queen F3 already it's almost
impossible for him to defend this
because if Queen t74 is hanging needs to
keep an eye on B6 too
um and yeah I mean he can play something
like Bishop B7 but then already I can
even start thinking about G4 and it
seems like Black's in pretty big trouble
here so he went for G5 but now I have to
look back to E4
um the point of this is that now I'm
gonna break with your H4 or F4 and the
only real way for him to
kind of defend is to go F5 at some point
um but whenever he does this after take
take like
we see the problem of the B6 weakness
now like yeah after rookie one rookie is
coming and he's Queen is stuck defending
everything and it's he's a big trouble
here
um
I think his best chance of Defense would
probably put the bishop on G6 somehow so
let's say after Bishop F5 I go back
maybe bishop G6 here and try to hold on
the king side on the king side but it's
still very tough for black
um because the way you play in the game
after C5 Queen H5
um yeah it's sort of a similar idea
where at some point I'm just going to go
f4h4 and once he fans with F6 I'm going
to be able to take and just crash around
the E file
so he played Bishop B7 which I think
made matters worse again I think he
probably has to try Bishop F5
and maybe something like Rook B8 so
defend B6 and the idea now is it's a
little bit tricky for me to for me to
break through here because if I go H4 he
does have the screen D7 move which is
kind of annoying because Bishop G4 radio
that if I stop to play F3 then use
Bishop G6
so
for that reason maybe I should put the
Rook on E1 actually and then here after
H4 isn't have the same Queen D7 idea but
here you can still go F6 and
at least he's still fighting here
because after take take let's say you're
like we have three now he's in time for
Queen D7 now that B6 is defended and
it's a little bit harder for me to crash
through here
um so
he played Bishop East I mean he tried to
create his own counter play along with
the long diagonal but it is a bit too
slow after rookie two
um already here like now that the
Bishop's stuck on on this diagonal when
I break with H4 and on crash on the
e-file this king's gonna be a lot weaker
now he doesn't have his Bishop on G6 to
defend so if you try Queen D5 but after
F4 this is hanging B6 is hanging yeah
um it's sort of crack it's sort of
falling apart here
um
he tried to be a little bit tricky with
F3 and F5 trying to close down the king
side so I finished the game off pretty
nicely I think with Richie two and King
F2 and he resigned here because okay
first thing he takes with the bishop I
have this nice trick Bishop takes H6
all his pieces and if he takes with the
queen Rook G1 Rook G8 check and take and
he runs out of Counter play Let's just
just made it a few moves yeah so it
looks like you had a pretty good start
to refer to your third round uh how are
you feeling going into your next round
you're probably gonna have the black
pieces right yeah yeah probably a black
and something really strong so it'll be
tough but I'm looking forward to the
challenge and I am glad I played a lot
better today than I did yesterday so
well I always love to hear it
we love to hear it here we hope to see
you back soon and thanks for coming on
man thank you
that was a beautiful presentation of the
the game thank you so much uh Brendan
for for getting us through uh your
thinking process and there was such a
such an amazing one one-way kind of game
where he he seemed to just be dominating
the king side and yeah thank you also of
course
Jacob for for uh interviewing that uh
for us and I'm bringing Braden Brendan
on board congrats for the win Brendan
and I really enjoyed that game yeah he
did a great job of explaining it and
again it's showing black moved one piece
away from the King side the bishop to B7
and all of a sudden it completely fell
apart because he didn't have a key
Defender over there when he was weak and
you know the other thing he made the
weakness with H6 which made F5 which was
a key defensive idea basically
impossible impossible yeah that was that
was great so and Brandon did a great job
of explaining that to everybody I really
enjoyed it so thanks again hopefully the
our viewers have enjoyed that as well uh
we're back with this game that had
finished as we pulled uh we were
watching the interview and it was kind
of crazy what happened in this game
where black we thought was dominating in
a way here having plenty of compensation
for the pawn on down and with the rook
in D2 We thought Knight D2 was an option
but it seemed that this position after
what do you say Bishop E2 this position
is supposed to be much better for white
according to the engine yeah I turned
out to be completely wrong in my
analysis here and what ends up happening
is that C5 Pawn becomes a monster and it
gets back to my earlier comment about in
these end games it's all about can you
control the squares in front of the pawn
so but white plays C6 and the problem
black has is if you move the Rook to E8
White's going to play C7 and put the
bishop on D6 and put a rook on B8 and
you know okay White's got a horrible
Pawn structure on the king side but he
can't move either his Rooks and
essentially the computers as white is
much better here and that's probably
right I don't see an obvious way to
clean the pawn but it's probably not any
more complicated than rookie one king F2
yeah both Rooks on the B file with the
bishop there that can be sustained with
a second C Pawn that can get all the way
to C5 to keep it there and that's
supposed to be a much better position
for white but crazy enough in a couple
of moves black ended up just blundering
here Bishop E2 was played and now
a natural move Rook B2 with the attempt
of keeping the Rook restricting whites
King from Castle on either side and just
basically keeping the pressure but as
soon as white played Bishop F3 I think
black did not realize that in this
position white although move 22 still
has the opportunity to Castle so he is
blundered with this move Bishop B5
um I hope I mean thinking that in case
white captures the Knight we have rookie
to check we get our piece back and then
it's going to be an opposite color
bishop and well with Rooks on the board
but differently to the previous position
we're analyzing this Pawn may not get to
be pushed that much forward because this
row could come maybe from from C4 and
and get it and stop it but he missed the
amazing The Amazing move long Castle
this move needs to be given like a
double X Club I think brilliant move
um by Fidel after which black is just
losing because now The Rook is hanging
the Knight is hanging there's no way to
protect both
um what uh what a turn of events in this
game we always thought that black was
doing fine was under preparation and
everything
and then
it's not enough to be prepared these
days you have to to train every single
part of the game you can have your
your openings down to the teeth but then
you know right and it's a great game by
Fidel because I mean he was clearly
Under Pressure being in preparation and
you know it seems like he was never
worse and he kept finding good moves and
and Fidel he was over 2 600 feet a
couple years ago I think he's fallen
victim to I know he's got two relatively
young children at home and he plays in a
lot of these open Swiss tournaments
where he's subjected to you know much
lower rated younger players who were
upcoming and that tends to damage your
rating but that's true certainly you
know he lived here in St Louis for a
number of years and he was well into the
2600s for quite a long time and he's a a
very talented player
I agree I had I had the chance to play
him one time
um I was doing really well actually I
was I was winning when I accepted the
draw but I was getting low on time so he
he offered the draw if I remember
correctly in
uh in the right time where I wasn't
quite sure how I would win but my time
was going down and I I failed to convert
my advantage by you know accepting the
drums well Grandmasters are good at
timing those draw offers that is true at
that that's true another result that we
had as we were watching the interview
was this game between elsewhere moradia
buddy and Christopher you that game
ended with a repetition around here I
thought that that white was able to
start pushing those pawns forward we saw
how elshon ended up winning that pawn
but the pressure on B3 wouldn't have
been easy to to deal with so he he
offered The Rook trade and and the draw
two and Christopher decided to take it
so
that was another result I think we
probably have a few more moves and this
result is not correct yet
still I don't know why we weren't able
to fix the results so this game is still
in progress I believe
we stopped somewhere around here after
Queen E8
and looks like Aaron has found a place
for the queen he's moving back and forth
hoping for a trade but that didn't
happen Rook G6
and that Queen is going to be attacked
so many times
um it was hard I I thought in the
beginning that remember I was I was
mentioning how Queen D3 was going to
bother one of the Bishops and then who
would have known that my my one sentence
was going to have an effect on things
right I I'm a little surprised he played
Queen to G3 and took the pressure off
the bishop on F5 Justin you know
sometimes Queens are annoying because
they attack so many things and on G5 the
queen is annoying on G3 it's not
annoying so I'm a little surprised by
that one but there's a threat there you
know what's yeah what what to do about
that move which which is very unpleasant
after that there would be a discovery so
he does need to move the queen somewhere
eventually
but I don't know
there's some other solution but
well he you know again he could
potentially move the Rook here yes but
yeah then this one is going to be
an issue I believe maybe not
Queen
right but you know if I play rookie one
and Bishop D3 and then I put my queen
back
um to E3 to E3 or G3 I'm not sure which
one but E3 is probably also just wait
one more move
but you don't think you're going to be
weakening
um F2 I mean I'm not it's not necessary
for me to move the bishop just yet right
maybe I could play a queen of fate
first
right and then I was always going to
play Bishop to E3
but uh aren't you going to have your
queen trapped
maybe not there right
yeah I think yeah yeah there's a problem
very sneaky I'm very sneaky yeah I
forgot to mention I forgot to mention
that when we first started I should have
I have some ideas that I I don't share I
don't know why
um
but um
yeah
it is hard to find a place for the queen
but
eventually I guess he still ended up
going back but he's allowed the black to
get a little bit of
of moves with Tempo quite a bit of
movement yeah quite a lot yeah Rook d8
that's an interesting choice for Talia
Rook d8
I'm not sure where she's going with that
Rook
um I would expect the queen to go
through a fate and then maybe be brought
that way and then Rook to f8 but
she might have tried to avoid
this move coming in with Tempo or
something
F3
okay white needs to take advantage of
the free move where he where his Queen
was not attacked
and just be annoying
oh this was a cool idea I always think
it's nice even in studies sometimes if I
really enjoy doing studies solving
studies I mean not yeah I I have created
a couple myself I have a collaboration
too that hopefully one day I will show
but
um when when you get to play a move like
F3 F4 F5 you know sometimes when you get
to push either a pawn or a rook or some
there are some studies that that are
kind of cool like that
so F3 and now here opening up the bishop
with the adf5
and of course I would love it if you
trade it but obviously black should not
trade to help white develop
so Italian Bishop C8 I don't know
right but this is a position to I want
to play F5 here is
wine
and seal everything in
so did she did she mess up with this
move Rook d8 because this was one move
where
she didn't
you know keep attacking that Queen so
much and
okay she cannot really attack it anymore
Bishop G5 does not seem to work just yet
but you can't play Queen of eight here I
think so so you're gaining control over
the F5 Square
to try to attack the Queen Once Again
what about F3 still it might still work
F3 but now we could go back back to F5
and just attack the queen
and then go back to H3 but then F4 will
still be an option this is a nice idea
for a white to to get that light Square
Bishop wherever he wants and then
try to get the pawn to F5 if that pawn
reaches F5 suddenly the stroke will have
to go away and it is white that could
utilize the extra space created for a
potential Rook lift and attack right and
that's what I'm thinking so so after did
they play F5 and G4 in the game he did
not play F5 he only played F4 and in
this position he finally developed his
bishop and now this bishop could go to
B6
B5 was played
so I guess Talia was maybe considering
to bring the bishop back to B7 instead
of keeping it there which makes sense
Knight had to go back
and now she took so she did not allow
the F5 Pawn the F4 Pawn to reach F5 and
that's a very double-edged idea if we go
back so instead of Bishop E3 if you play
F5 here and Black's gonna play Rook F6
you know the Pawn's not guarded so you
can either Play Bishop E4 or G4 here
probably with the Rook on d8 you might
have to play G4 and that that could have
been her idea and G4
why do I need to play G4 oh you're right
the pawn is guarded still so I can play
Bishop G5 yeah
I think
I don't think you can take I was
thinking maybe some tactical ideas but I
don't think you can take an F5 right now
um
so I'm comfortable in this position yeah
yeah
you have you have a blockade on the
pawns so I'm a little bit surprised that
he didn't go he played Bishop E3 he
probably has been struggling I mean it's
moved 30 and he still hasn't touched
these two pieces so he was probably
thinking I've had enough of random peace
movement it's time to get this bishop in
but he could have missed this nice
opportunity of first blocking the
position one more move he had to make
and this Rook does not seem to have a
another way out other than here
I don't see any in between checks or no
sir Rook F6 is kind of necessary and
then and I don't know if you want to
play Bishop G5 in you may not want to
trade the Bishops but after Bishop Chief
no but I say after Bishop G5 to drive
the Rook back which is probably a good
idea you drive it back to the back ring
where do I want to put my Bishop maybe I
want to put it on D2 instead of e3 so if
B5 I've got E3 for the night ah okay
that's a nice idea as well and then I
can bring the Rook over and my knight is
really controlling it's guarding F5
again oh I've got this bishop G5 I know
I know see you just need to show me one
idea in the neither and that I'm just
going to do it all the time
um although I saw a tweet some days ago
it was I thought I thought it was really
funny when my friend shared it by Geary
Anish giri he was saying something like
you know you cannot play G6 on King's
Indian against all openings or something
like that but but you can go Bishop G5
but again if you do that do do I care
that much if I just play Rook 81 and if
I let you trade the bishop fine I've got
the bishop here I've got all your you
know squares blockaded and I mean this
Pawn is going to be my my target
um yeah but you take with the Rook
if I take your ticket to Rook right I
can take with the rug
to do that that's a lucky idea otherwise
I was planning to go Queen H5 and and
get the pawn but this way you can defend
you might even have this in between move
potentially which
may or may not work might not work
because the bishop takes F5 yeah you
know and in these positions there's
always chances for dynamic play for
black because you've got Knight E7 to
chase the bishop or trade the bishop and
then all of a sudden you know black
might have a monster Bishop on B7 so
yeah F5 is double edged I it's probably
not it attracts more weaknesses maybe
yeah it's probably not quite as good as
I thought that it was
but why not why not here because b592
and then black is going to put pressure
on that pawn but but now black doesn't
have that move so you can't touch the
queen because that's hanging right
so how was I why was I why was I I was
why was I making this move nobody was
saying anything uh I couldn't make that
move that move is not possible but we're
going 97. oh that's how we were
improving it right right right yeah
um okay
so
I don't know
um I think Bishop E3 I would like but
okay yeah but but F5 is a more
double-edged I think than you know what
I was suggesting here because of the
idea of um it also sometimes if you're
not sure and you feel that you want to
make your opponent think a little bit
longer
um after Knight D2 then
um you know you get you get this uh this
idea with F5 so you're letting black
decide a little bit longer okay do I
like this do I care about this F5 move
being pushed or or not and um and yeah I
don't know but but typically e takes F4
gives squares to the black pieces here
E5 for the Knight the bishop on F6 is a
little bit better placed right um the
The Rook is still a little strange on
you know G6 it's a little exposed
it doesn't have a good company does not
have
pieces that help it
um build up the attack so
she's bringing the Knight which I like I
think this bishop in Eve in D5 turned
out to remain a pretty strong piece it
does not allow Bishop B7
and how do you chase it away from there
maybe you don't and we're back to the
White Queen being chased
that's uh never-ending game
Bishop E4 so he left with the Bishop
from that outpost on his own
like I don't I guess he just wanted this
Rook
gone from the G file so that he could
chase the bishop away but was this the
right thing to do
Bishop back here and
how does white plan on continuing this
because
okay maybe he's trying to get again to
an end game if he Trace more pieces this
this is going to be a good
yeah I think this is it's still a
fighting game here there's lots of
pieces on the board and um you know
black has a weakness on D6 which isn't
that easy to get to but you know black
still has activity my gut reaction is is
because of the structural advantages
white should be a tiny bit better here
but with the peace activity it's it's
probably not much
that remains to be seen both of the
players are approaching
um time travel shall we say more like
Talia is a little bit lower on time but
um if the times are correct I don't know
what's going on we we don't see the
exact times until until they make a move
then the new times okay sounds good all
right so let us go back to the first
boards it's been a while since we we've
been to the first board in this event uh
Nicolas theodoro against Doris schweartz
and
I do not like this bishop
at all but does white have sufficient
um positional advantage
on the
should have
you know if the readers recall this
started out as a rui Lopez 5d3 I know I
know I already has played G6 early on
similar to his game yesterday I know
which is a known idea in these lines um
uh but it transposed to something more
like uh
um I would say
non-meron Queens can be accepted or that
that pawn structure with the pawns there
and these pawns here or some kind of
slav let's see yeah yeah but there's no
bonus if I I don't know what what it
looked like I was just mesmerized by the
by the position I was trying to figure
out what how did that position happen
but I guess those positions could arise
from from the yeah a lot of times black
is playing for a quick D5 when he puts
his Bishop on G7 and black never
achieved that here and again without
looking at it deeply I'm not sure why
but but maybe he was just trying to play
solidly here so he took the bishop not
with the Rook that's interesting
probably
this file this opening of the file in
the real Lopez or Italian oftentimes is
just
uh
unclear to me what is happening with the
file because it's available it's there
but oftentimes you don't have the
opportunity to get activated on the
second or seventh rank so you just have
the file there and nobody seems to care
about what is going to happen on on the
file and
um and we we see that black captures
with the bishop doesn't even want to
think to take with the Rook which is
interesting to me maybe their ideas with
uh with Queen B1 B2 and Rook Rook A1
right but black can always counter by
putting the queen back to d8 yeah of
course regarding the file so yeah taking
with the bishop seems like a strange
decision to me because one of the points
of the D3 Roy Lopez is to blunt the
bishop on B7 so you you and that's why I
said when the Bishops on G7 black
usually plays for D5 in these positions
because he can soften up the white pawns
on C3 and D3 right
albeit he's also exposing himself
because he's opening the position
because it's a square for the Knight on
e4 and and also in this particular
position that Knight can go to E4 and
then C5 true true but in the same yeah
because the bishop is on G7 as opposed
to maybe on on B6 or A7 or or on this
other diagonal to control C5 but
um but it's it's it's a play it's a game
that that ends up happening so I I don't
know okay let's see Patrick is saying
that taking with the Rooks black down
from playing D5 for even longer and yeah
I think he's right because what it does
is it takes a Defender away from the
evening
that but but you don't have pressure on
that pawn just stand and I I don't I
don't think I mean but how how exactly
is that happening when I take with the
nine my Bishop opens up so I I would
have to disagree with him
I usually don't get very strong with my
chat but this time this time Sabine is
getting combative
we're we're trying to be to be more more
aggressive here uh no I I I I wouldn't
say it if I wouldn't be
you know quite sure because I
I'm trying to to find some utility for
this bishop and that's that's a great
great
great idea typically I've played systems
uh in the real opposed with G6 a couple
of times I usually don't get good
positions but you know that's me you
know I'm not I'm not a GM right now who
knows maybe one day
um
but
yeah so but but I mean these positions
are hard to play because both sides have
to calculate you know playing D5 and D4
in almost every position and and what
happens when the pawn structure changes
I think sometimes there are even ideas
when black plays D5 for white to play
but I'm thinking here you wouldn't want
this with white because black has double
fianchetta which means that both those
Bishops will get to be open and that's
at least normally not something you want
to do
but how did white get that pawn over
there right yeah I'm still I'm still you
know trying to understand how that
happened because I just loved White's
position okay so he just went for it and
Darius just
didn't want to take
okay so that's how it happened he
probably did not want to take because
he did not want to take
because he doesn't have a way to attack
the center after this I think E5 and and
this Knight is is coming to C5 and the
position is just
yeah it it's just unpleasant and could
black play D5 directly
just counter attack the center just like
that
I I would I would love to play this move
if
it works if it works if it works I I
have to be I have to be mindful about
this idea I I understand I understand
that's that's a very unpleasant idea why
did he did he have to go by Bishop E7
couldn't he have just kept his Bishop in
A8 and yeah here
because you know the bishop in B7 when
the Knight comes to C5 it's a fork but
this way there's no Fork we can just go
D5 directly you know
maybe I'm being too yeah too aggressive
but all of these positions are
double-edged so it's hard to say with
certainty
isn't that square guarded it is I was
gonna I was gonna be sneaky I was going
to be sneaky but I think there's Knight
C5 in between move here
and
um where do we move the queen
back to d8 and what is going on
yeah see I get a little nervous in these
Pawn structures for black because after
you know I take once I I'm gonna have
the B3 or A2 F7 diagonal and it's going
to be very hard for black to challenge
that at some point I don't get it right
away I know the Knight hits B4
I'm deciding whether I'll take with the
night or the pawn so trade is going to
happen for whom is it better I would
have more space so technically I should
not trade that night we're about to have
an interview with Fidel Corrales oh all
right that'll give Sabine and I a chance
to come to grips of what's really going
on in this game here
yes
uh let's get that rolling
I am with Grand Master Fidel Corrales
fresh off of his win against Grandmaster
Iran Jacobian Fidel you just played an
amazing game with an amazing little
spicy ending you know take us all
through it and show the people what you
did thank you yeah it was a it was a it
was a very good game uh there was a lot
of complications and uh
um yeah so let's uh yeah let's take a
look at it
um so basically I play Queen's Gambit uh
and I was expecting a nimso so he he
played you know that's what he plays the
most I think and uh and I played the the
the samish variation of the names of
Indian and uh and here after D5 A3
Bishop takes Pawn takes so First bishop
takes was surprising because before
on the database he had played Bishop E7
and Bishop D6 so I wasn't really sure I
was expecting that and his impressed me
with this special Tech C3 pontex C3 and
then D takes E4 I have actually never
seen this move before so that was uh
yeah that was a big surprise for me but
I you know normally C5 is the best
movies on C takes D5 and that's just
like you know mainly stuff
uh but here he goes D-Day C4 and I you
know when you don't you've never seen a
move before usually you know inaccuracy
no but yeah but I the way he was playing
he felt like he knew what he was doing
so I you know I just kind of played
logical so E4 trying to take the ball on
C4 he played B5 protecting the pawn I
play A4 he has to play C6 only move
and now Bishop A3 I mean this seems to
extremely logical to me because I'm just
cutting off the game so he played he
played Knight fd7
another surprising move too I mean
basically everyone we make for now we're
kind of like what is happening here so
Knight fd7 has two goals here one is to
play C5
and the other one is playing Knight B6
but it is a very strange move anyway
like you know I was I wasn't really so
yeah I spent like 30 minutes and I play
F4 I'm not I'm not sure this is the best
move uh but it looked logical to me
because I'm playing I'm trying to go
knife three and development nine the
other way I could play was Knight E2 G3
I thought about that oh Knight H3 I just
need to basically get out of the center
develop and attack so I thought I
thought it was the fastest make but then
later maybe I don't know maybe not the
best we will see so anyway he plays A6
also a good move because he wants to
play C5 next and then I just developed
my knight so now I'm gonna move ahead
I'm basically two moves away from
wrestling there should be too Castle
and he has to do something because his
bees are kind of weird like I thought he
was gonna pay Knight B6 but then I can
just you can probably just take the pawn
yeah and keep that Bishop down that's
very nice
so here he went C5
and at this point I I just don't know if
I have to take but I feel like I have to
because he's asking so I was like okay
let me take the phone back so I just got
the phone back then he played Bishop
peace out I was expecting that and then
here's another position that is very
interesting I had a lot I have a lot of
options here I thought Queen D4 was
interesting and maybe
maybe even Bishop B2 giving up yeah
that's the first thing I think of
but then he was he could go Castle well
actually he doesn't have Castle because
I have C6 right so I don't know I spent
on quite a few time here thinking about
even Queen B1 that was actually a pretty
interesting move Queen B1 defending and
attacking the bottom B5
but then he maybe can go live six
and I wasn't sure about that position
because my
you I could take the bottom be five
maybe
yeah I don't know I I thought I I was
like I got excited about the my move
Queen D6 I'm not sure how good that move
is
especially after what happened in the
game but this move seems pretty strong
because right now basically he cannot
take the pawn
because I have something like Rook D1 or
even Knight G5 then yeah you get a lot
of counter play on this side yeah it's
scary because I got Knight takes E6 I
got C6 and he puts the bishop on D5 I
can go Rook D5 and then boom Brook this
bishop and it's like completely lost
yeah but then he finally I have six so I
thought it was a good move too and then
here I'm actually have to play very
accurate because if I go E5
he can just trade queens and then Knight
D5 and somehow my pawns are weird
I wasn't sure about that position
maybe I'm maybe I'm missing something
but he felt like my points were blocked
and then he saw that in all my pieces I
hold my pawns on C3 F4 so I wasn't
really I wasn't really sure about that
so I played I played I was very I think
like before was a great move too because
now he takes the bottom what I want I
want to take this B5 Pawn so that then I
can take C4 yeah and I thought it makes
sense so he then he found all I know
it's really interesting move Knight C6
so the idea is that he wants to keep
this Pawns
so if I go for example
let's say Pawn takes B5
to try to get the pawn on B5 he's gonna
take on B4 yeah first and then take on
B5 then my then all of my Pawns in the
center kind of blocked on hanging when
he has two pass points right and then
these this Rook is pinned too so it's
very weird the bishop Spencer
so like you know like let's say Pawn
takes B5 Knight takes nine
he could also take in fact he should
probably take first but it doesn't
matter there is that
um he can take and then let's just say
that I take back here I thought my
position was just much worse here
because he's playing before next move
yeah my pawns are not doing anything
here like this is probably almost like
mine might even be lost here somehow
yeah it's definitely doing a lot better
yeah like you know if I play five look
at the look at the bishop the nine look
at my pieces are weird
um yeah this position looks horrifying I
didn't want to do that I only have one
pass point just two and they're gone
like my pieces are all out so that that
was not an option for me here so then I
I realized so I he missed this move I
think that he misses move but I'm I'm
not sure Queen takes Queen Rook takes
and then the next move obviously if I
take the pawn he takes the Knight again
yeah so I was like no I gotta take the
Knight with the knife first so there is
no Nike snipe but this move is a bomb
this Knight takes B5 only I thought
maybe the only movie spontane so
otherwise I'll just take the pawn and C4
so he takes takes and here he has a big
array of big problem I mean he cannot
even think about going let's say Knight
A5 or not A7 or because I'm just playing
C6 yeah he's gonna be down a Rock
basically for the rest of the game so
that's pretty easy for me so then he's I
think he made the right choice he took
with the pawn so gave me back the knife
take take
and then here if I take the pawn on C4
he has this annoying move
so then I'm paying and I'm I might be
okay but the promise I also cannot
Castle
because you have Knight D2
uh so I got some issues there right and
then if I cannot Castle then how can I
get out of this pin coin Bishop B2 no
that's not an option for me I don't
think I'm worse but he's taking my Pawn
on C5 actually I think I am worse I
might be a slightly worse here so I
didn't like that because that just takes
away on my initiative and then I just I
just simply played Bishop before so now
my Rook is active
I could be playing some Rook A6 followed
by C6 and then he cannot Castle so he
has to that's what I think
maybe here he can make something and
more precise but I don't I couldn't see
anything right away
maybe Knight D2
to try to get rid of my Bishop
but then I have some cases like I can
just play Rook A6 and then C6
yeah you're probably a little fast there
yeah I think I'm definitely better here
so he make I think Castle looks very
logical then here I have to also make an
important decision should I take the
pawn or should I not should I play
Bishop V2 and I think I made the right
choice because Bishop takes C4 I think
it's best I feel
then now here his best move and I
thought that was the move he was gonna
play
um it was nine the wait wait
was it 92
no no 92 I just played Bishop B2 yeah no
no actually this I thought this was
gonna be the movie like he would play 92
Bishop E2 then he takes on G2 Rook G1
now F3 check Bishop takes 9 which takes
Bishop then I have this move C6 and I I
thought this was the key move moment of
the game here C6 if it goes Bishop takes
then I take and I'm playing for a win I
think I'm the only one who win here then
if he goes rookie a I'm playing C7 and I
feel like this position is the only one
who can actually shoot for a wins me
because I got this move Bishop A5 my I'm
actually gonna play King F2 tempo
then let's say he goes Rook CA I just go
I just go Bishop by five and then my
plan is easy I just play King F2 Rook D1
I put a monster Rook on D A yeah and I
feel like if somebody I mean his
passports are very hard to get created
then I got C4 C5 I just I feel like this
is probably just marching on down
slightly better he cannot block me
neither because I got C4 so when I go to
D1 root d8
or Rook whatever D2 or E3 I just go once
I put my Rook on the air then he's
basically almost suits on there he
cannot move
so maybe he can make something with E5
and Bishop G4 I know there might be
something he can do but I feel like or
maybe I can play King F2 first and then
uh to define the bishop and then I go
then now I can also play Rook A7
D6 this looks scary though
yeah like any of these positions feel
like I'm the only one I mean I look at
my king boom boom but I have an extra
cane basically so yeah this was I
thought this was gonna be a good
position maybe you have to suck the
exchange and put that and make a draw
there but but no he he surprised me
again he played Rook D2
and after Bishop video I felt he also
missed that move
because maybe he was expecting me
castling and then he has some like
Knight takes C3 stuff like that yeah or
Knight 65 or something like that I don't
know Knight D6 actually wait 96 is
better that's that's better any move
with this yeah so no that's not an
option of course but then I have Bishop
B2 and I feel like he's just slow he's
just much worse now Mama born rubbishop
pair
he doesn't have a threat I just don't
see anything here
then crazy enough he in two moves he
resign
so he I thought he was gonna play like
something like Rook CA or D.A you know
Ruby 2 which was also basically no
matter what I play where he plays I'm
playing Bishop F3 right that's my next
move on Castle so he's gonna go Ruby too
and then I spray Bishop a three now his
pin I got I'm castling sure once again I
thought he was gonna play Knife too to
get rid of my the visual pair Castle
Bishop takes pressure and then group
text F2 and then that position I feel
like it takes Rock intakes and I
evaluated this might be the best thing
he has but it's still it's gonna be a
huge amount of suffering for him yeah
it's going to be really hard for you
have to play Rook CA and I can play like
I can maybe go G4 G but I just played G3
and then I'm just gonna March my cane
right boom boom I also thought that I
had this cool idea Bishop A5 now before
he opens the hole here
so that if Rook a I got root C7
so so he plays let's say H6 and then I
now go Bishop B6 and now and now I cut
him off completely like look he cannot
even move the room so now now three King
King King and he cannot even check me
like this is yeah maybe I think this
might be a draw objectively but it's
kind of a long it's going to be really
hard to find exactly I also have ideas
like I can sack The Rook for the bishop
like when I came I came Super Active I
guess oh yeah something like Rook takes
bishop and then King B5 you know so he's
got to worry about everything also how
about just bringing the king of 2e5 well
he well he's gonna play F6 but then he's
cut off right but if he does and then I
go King E5 and then Rook C7 and I win
the different color bishoping because
the king can never make the king is nine
times it feels like stuff like that you
know so this was bad maybe this is what
he saw or he wanted to try to throw a
win then here I thought it was gonna be
Rook C8 and that's the symbological move
here too because he he might wanna he
might be better for him to get rid of
the bishop
and then here I was just gonna Castle
sure because he doesn't have Knight D2
right because then I got Bishop takes
bishop and it's over it's locked
straight
oops what did I do here
I just won so Bishop B2
uh three but then here he goes bishoply
fine enough for me a draw but he's just
that lost
and I had a feeling that he was gonna
blunder that I I felt like because this
is a move that he had even before
uh no actually he never had it before
but he he was gonna have it no let's say
Rook da Bishop F3 he was gonna have it
at any point
like yeah he's gonna try and invade
itself but then in this case that's why
he moved to Rook I got to see if I got
this beautiful C4 right so like Bishop
B5 C4 bank bam and I know attacking
again don't block and then I take the
Knight and sword right I love that
actually maybe Rook D4 is possible Pawn
takes Bishop this bishop but then I saw
something like C6 I should be winning
this uh the last ones I get stuck gets
tricky a little quickly yeah so so
basically that's why he played Ruby too
no he wanted to go to get the bishop B5
but he missed the beautiful long castle
Yeah I right whenever I saw this move
back and I was like I I spent like a
couple of minutes here just to make sure
that I mean I like this is like resign
like he had to resign now like this is
overnight two there's no Rook move
there's no tricks Bishop takes nine it's
always cool when you get to play a lot I
thought he was gonna play rookie too but
this is also lost right I just take I
was thinking about taking taking a look
at this
no even not even time for for wasting
just span C6
I don't even want my Rook I just wanted
the pawn that's it that's awesome then
now he cannot even take because I'm
going to do
these are the times I was thinking about
this I was adding chocolate but I think
it does does work
so he then he goes through take the
bishop the only move to not lose the
exchange but do not lose the night then
I now I can move my Rook but let's
activate my game because I needed I
needed to push the pawns and use them
that's it sometimes you just gotta look
at a game and just just smile at it you
know
it was nice I mean I I would play I
think I play I play decent maybe maybe
there were some mistakes maybe I could
play a lot a little better in the
beginning
maybe my queen D6 was not as good as I
thought but
but overall I think I never I was never
worse I think I was probably around
equality maybe a little better until
yeah until he left me he at the end I
think I'm just really really better uh
basically I think Bishop we do I think
is when the chain when the game already
sort of took a turn exactly I think this
is all right better for me like really
better and at least he's gonna be
suffering for a long time any other
position the other position that I show
will probably maybe better for him
I mean it's always really good to start
the third round with the nice win you
know that's going to put you at what two
and a half two and a half out of three
that's an amazing score you're now in
tied first because Mr Andy Paul took a
round buy this turn so you're tied for
first how are you feeling I'm feeling
great I'm feeling good you know playing
2600 I got one and a half out of two
that's a big deal so it's always a big
deal and we'd love to hear it good luck
to you in the next round Fidel and
thanks for coming on thank you share it
thank you so much Jacob for bringing
that interview what an enthusiastic
Fidel Corrales you guys have seen I
really enjoyed that interview especially
his enthusiasm about being able to cast
along that was that was great Doug what
did you think I I thought it was a great
count uh you know interview
Fidel's a great guy he's always happy
and I'm looking at Patrick your comment
here about oh man Fidel is going to beat
himself up over that comment that I was
never worse and I I don't know exactly
where you're referring to Patrick in
terms of where he was worse I I know he
didn't think that black could play
Bishop takes E4 which you know Sabine
and I have turned on the computer and
the computer seems I think this is the
best movement it's about equal after
19.94 yeah but but in in his interview
he was mentioning more like 95 Rook D1
but that Bishop D5 seems to kind of keep
black skin safe for the moment and then
try to get the queen away
um but also you're saying 84 and King
takes d8 was better for black so
and exactly what move Patrick were you
referring to here
um you're saying Knight D4 was minus one
mind here really oh okay well you're
probably using a stronger computer than
we are yeah
14. yeah so yeah it's not shocking to me
that black would be better in this
position and I think when we were doing
the commentary we thought that this was
you know the the best oh maybe maybe he
met he means in this position after the
trade maybe he means in this position
because here we did talk about this
position
um and was it here no sorry quintix the
air and here's the Rook taxi maybe he
talks about yeah because that was the
move that he suggested earlier and that
was that was definitely the move that
was was bringing black a much better
position but earlier we were talking
about that position
um here
um so you are you are correct there and
again you know this is one of these
games it's a fascinating game to watch
it's extraordinarily complex and you
know as you can see the grand Masters
they don't know exactly what's going on
when they're playing these games it's
easy to have a narrative after the game
yeah
um he um shared with us was that after
playing Bishop B5 his opponent offered a
draw not realizing that after Castle it
is game over so I don't know if he
really didn't realize or he tried last
thing hoping for white to forget about
the fact that long Castle is possible
but
the water game that was and the
interview so yes it was a fun game and
um definitely requires more more
analysis I really
um
and I think you know Fidel did a very
nice job explaining that and I you know
I'm happy with the analysis that Sabina
and I did on this I think you know we
came up with at least a lot of the ideas
there and it was a fun game to look at
but uh let's go back because as we're
approaching uh time travel and there is
I don't even know if I if I call it time
travel because the time control if you
guys remember is 90 minutes plus 30
seconds increment and that's it no
additional time no 40 moves you know no
Southern does nothing like that's it an
hour and 30 minutes and uh players are
approaching the end of that maybe they
even finish their games as you guys may
remember there is a delay in showing the
games we are live a hundred percent so
we are here but they may be done with
their games while we are waiting for the
moves to show up
um and we left off the position
somewhere around here well actually a
little bit earlier when I was trying
very much to make this D5 move possible
a little bit earlier but it seems like
in the end it was
um Queen it was it was made but a little
bit too late for black probably because
the position
seems so so much better for white
from a positional standpoint because now
there's that Outpost E5 was possible and
I really enjoy White's position here
yeah and when you're referring to the
Queen's game but there are some lines in
the slav where you know white can force
the B5 Pawn 4 and you get this Knight
position here so it really is
reminiscent of a semi sloth here that
went wrong for black when you look at
this position I mean there's differences
of course but it's not impossible for
this to arise from that opening even
though it's an E4 rui Lopez I I totally
agree and I really loved White's idea
here it's an idea that you and I have
talked about in other games this h4h5
idea to weaken the king but not
necessarily to just weaken the king but
get age six in as soon as maybe maybe
Darius is trying to go for a draw here
repeating the position but now or maybe
because the Knight moved he was trying
to get to H4 but now H6 was played and
what are you doing because if you put
the bishop in h8 it's going to be
restricted by these two pawns but if you
put the bishop in f8
you're still not really having a better
life you have to try to find a way to
get it somehow into play either that way
or somehow through here if you manage to
it's and uh and in that case still black
skin is quite weak if then I guess to
have sex it's going to be very
unpleasant and Knight G4 is played with
the idea Knight F6
maybe black skin
finds itself safe for the moment because
especially because the position is
closed there's no Queen coming in yet
but you know this is one of those things
where the computers in Leela and and
there was this book Game Changer that
came out a couple years ago that's
changed our understanding of Chess and
when that pawn gets to H6 you know the
the black king is in danger from the
queen because of the possibility of
Checkmate on G7 and even though
obviously the White Queen isn't anywhere
close to that it's always a danger and
even if you trade into an end game black
has a problem that is King can't stray
very far from that pawn because if he
loses the H7 Pawn to you know say a
knight or even a sacrifice on G6 with a
bishop at the F pawn moves toward the
pawn can Queen so effectively in a lot
of these end games black is playing a
piece down in the piece he's playing
down is the king yeah and the King
becomes very much valuable in an end
game we don't have a physical value that
we're giving to the king like points
like we're giving to the other pieces
but you know that the king is is very
important to stop past pawns to maybe
grab some of your opponent's pawns and
create your own pass pawns and not being
able to bring it into play is going to
be
very tough for black to deal with this
position I was at a chess Camp a year
ago and one of the trainers there was
Magnus Carlson's second Peter Heine
Nielsen and he was showing us a position
out of their preparation where in the
classical King's Indian White pushed his
pawn
a4a5a6 and allowed black to play B6 and
normally in the classical King's Indian
with Bishop B2 Knight F3 D5 you know
white wants to open up the queen side
and his point was is that after you fix
the pawn on
A7 is white can put a knight on B5 he
can put his Bishop on E3 you trade all
the pieces and then you can actually
sack both pieces on A7 and B6 and white
will have two pass pawns and they'll
Queen and win the game nice and it was
literally fascinating they were looking
at this from a long-term perspective
that if you lock the pawn structure like
this It ultimately it was a winning
position and so here I and I'm not
saying that white is winning this
position right here but this is a
position that black is going to suffer
in forever because he cannot extricate
his King from the corner
that's that's totally true and and even
if you know white trades or black trades
the Queens here and then the night on F6
um there's entry squares for the Bishops
you know on A5 and a white I'll have to
bring the king all the way to A5 to try
and get in that way yeah get the bishop
in somewhere and how does the Knight
keep the uh the king out it would have
to be on B7 I I also think for white if
Queens get traded off the board it's not
easy of course white has to kind of
figure it out maybe get the bishop to C3
I was about to say F4 G4 F5 I think that
is the the right plan for for white in
in this position just make sure that the
queen of blacks does not get activated
because you really do have like someone
was saying earlier tribal style
capablanca travel style position not
exactly as good for not exactly as
dominating for white but certainly quite
um like it was in that game where all of
black species were dead here's just the
king and this bishop in B7 but that
could prove to be enough for white I
really would love to go here I don't
even think I would go on the king yeah
on the queen side just just do this they
have no time left which will be in they
don't have much time left no five
minutes left
um all together and okay with the with
the 30 seconds increment the games may
have already been over but another
interesting game is board two with Ilia
and uh Brian Escalante here what is
going on in this end game it's too
connected past pawns for white actually
white is
but they're not that far Advanced yeah
but that's the right corner Bishop which
means this Knight won't be able to be
sacrificed for the Pawns
so if this King manages to stop those
but I I think this it has to be
calculated okay yeah that I would have
played that instantaneously now the
problem is this Knight will go to A7 and
it's hard to get the Knight away from a
dark Square so the question is do we
bring in our King a little bit to be
closer to the E Pawn or do we have time
to push
if we push here what happens does
blackplay Knight D7 or does he push E4
this is the type of position where you
have to calculate you can't just go by
feelings
um very much
um
yeah I mean I'm sure this is you know a
position the computer can figure out
yeah 100 whether it's a winner a loss
for one but but if you allow this I
think white is I think white should be
winning
King C2 and uh right I think when the
pawn gets to B4 you have to put your
knife yeah you need to make this move
yes
so now
um
do we this bishop in H1 I love it very
much because it blocks the H Pawn but in
the same time if this move is going to
be played we'll have to figure out what
to do
Bishop C6 is probably not the wisest
idea because
I've got the pawn stopped
so we cannot just subtly magically make
the bishop go there it would be possible
if it would be possible then we would
not be talking I mean it's very possible
that this position is just a draw
because the Knight has the pawns
blockaded and neither side can improve
I.E white can't you know move the king
up to C4 C5 because the pawned Queen
I think black and green disc blockade
and you know with a knight here because
this way the night with the pawn and the
King they kind of restrict white skin
from going up
and you know pushing the pawn and giving
it up it's not going to help white in
any way because then the Knight can just
be sacrificed from the pawn
but I don't know if this could be a
zucson kind of position I don't think so
so is there a way for right after Knight
C8 to not to get this bishop stuck so
Patrick is telling us that the engine
says that this is zero zero zero which
really isn't that surprising because I I
don't think that um black can try and
win because The Bishop's long-range
capability so that that's probably but
when I was looking at the game from afar
um it was kind of interesting I don't
know what the current position is but uh
the position is here now nothing has
changed it's nice nothing's changed no
new move has appeared not yet no and
then in turn and then there was this
game again of Gillette duden against
Yasser quesada Perez
um with an extra Palm for white but what
do we have here
no possibly a second Pawn is going to be
captured I should be winning this game
black has some activity but that's about
all he has I think once we capture that
pawn we can just bring in the king and
this is a pretty big upset
um Casada Perez over at Webster
University they worship him for his
understanding of Chess even the higher
rated players over there they disbelief
his understanding of the game is at very
very high so even though the rating
differential here is only a hundred and
say 40 points uh
yes or Casada Perez is a very very
strong player so this is a big upset I'm
really surprised about White's choice to
go like this you know one thing that
I've learned as a long time professional
player although I know my rating is not
very high right now and you might not
want to believe me but that's okay I'll
give you the advice anyways in positions
when you're winning or in positions
where you think they're a draw Don't
Force
the draw yeah yeah don't force don't try
to force the draw or the win you are
going to mess things up and I don't like
that before I could be totally wrong
but that seems like a little bit there
was nothing no threat whatsoever in a
loud counter play yeah why would you do
that get a loud counter play because you
know if these pawns get traded here
and you don't stay with your extra
password which you won't like it's just
gave up a poem for free like I don't
understand well I I think doesn't white
get the pawn back with Rook A1 it takes
A5 but you left yourself with a weak
sign up on and a weakness on G2 I
understand but how how exactly I mean
I'm right right you gave it back and now
you're at four or three yeah yeah and
and those are blocked so
yeah yeah that's what what was what was
happening here what what was what was in
White's mind here why would he do that
are we missing any tactical idea for
black I know I don't see anything
trading the bishop is that something
even about I mean I would be happy with
white if you train my Bishop right
because we just
I mean I can even play King G3
am I missing something here
you can then play B4 once those Bishops
are traded you don't even need to do it
right right if you trace the Bishops
right you can play B4 you can lose one
of the pawns but if you have the outside
a pawn and you got an extra Pawn the
king's side it has to be a winning end
game yeah this this should be this
should be winning I believe
because I mean you don't need to trade
these pawns off like once you know let's
just assume something like this could
happen and then you can put your Rook
here and then you can just bring in the
king just put your Pawn on the way to E6
and bring in the king to go grab this
Pawn
you might be able to win even if you
play F4 because even if that gets traded
or if you take then you have a six so
you're winning in this either way if you
think about this position black has to
play Rook C5 right away to guard the
pawn or otherwise you're just going to
play Rook A5 and take it even worse
right well is that gonna be easier to
win in I prefer to have a further way
possible than to take that right but
what I'm saying is is if you don't play
Rook C5 I'm going to play Rook A5 and
you don't really have a way to guard the
pawn ever now I can improve my king and
I can choose one to take the pawn
correct you can't you can't play King E7
because I take the check and I go back
so you you almost have to play Rook C5
here as black
and then I can just improve the position
at my my leisure so we don't know what
the B4 seems terrible
I mean let's just see let's just see
what the engine says just in case
yeah it just gives up all the advantage
and so in B4 it goes to zeros yeah it
goes to 0.5 yeah well that's but but it
says Bishop C8 though so there is
something here that we are is this an
idea for black
maybe that's finally something that I
can come up we can come up with
it could be annoying okay so
so now we see that there's something
that could be unpleasant to think about
but okay all right in that case we don't
take we could go maybe
Bishop c86 V5 to kind of have our pawns
protected
over there and then we can go before if
that's what we want to do that so it's
harder than what we were saying it's a
little bit harder I
I was I was totally missing Black's
counter play so there is something there
anyways but but still this seems a
little bit too soon allowing the
uh
wow he let the seat he let the a pawn
yeah right White's still being ambitious
here but um white has been a little bit
too ambitious what uh what is he
planning to do after this
yeah because that Bishop on G4 is not
that great it doesn't have a lot of
scope yeah
threatening ideas if that was a night on
the other case it would have been
brilliant but but if he was going to
play B4 because he was concerned about
the counter play I I don't know why he
wouldn't have eliminated the a pawn just
said okay the pawn up and all the pawns
are on the same side and I'm going to
agree to a drawn and go on whereas here
White's risking
I don't know what the evaluation is here
but um
but I play Rook C3 A3 or Rook D4 but
this is a position that white could lose
even though the evaluation doesn't show
I would never allow uh I would never
want to allow I have done it in the past
but he must be really desperate he must
be very desperate to try to win this
position for for allowing the the a pawn
but why is he
yeah in a recent Tournament of mine I I
took an extra Pawn like this and I
couldn't you know extricate my king side
and all of a sudden the pawn on the
queen side became a monster and I lost
and I was highly agitated at myself for
that um
stupidity of trying to win from a
position that it really shouldn't have
tried to
so and again I mean objectively Black's
not in trouble or White's not in trouble
but yeah but you it's just unpleasant to
play with such a Far Far Away possible
and that's protected and the bishop can
be chased away they might agree on a
draw very soon in this game I have a
feeling the other two games left here
were this one of Aaron against Talia
that we spent quite some time on earlier
but now
um
what has happened he has he has a
he has a pawn for The Rook is there mate
coming is there Unstoppable mate after
this move Queen to G5
their two mates that I see or three if
you're an account that G7 squares two
options is there a way for black to
defend that mate
I don't see one
so how did he oh wow okay so so he took
advantage of this pin after Bishop to D3
and play Rook F7 which is a very nice
very nice move to bring in a piece to
the attack and after Rook takes G7 you
kind of have to recapture otherwise
Bishop F6 comes in and mate or even
Bishop F6 no just just Bishop F6
and now Dalia had to go to h8 or else
there's Queen G5 coming with mate
there's no choice it's made in one
otherwise now and now it's made or she
lost some time yeah I don't see a
difference that's a very nice finish for
air in there
wow imagine that more than probably 75
percent of the moves that he's made in
this game or with the queen I mean I was
it's I don't even know what to say that
it gives up all the rules or chess you
know you just whatever you learn is just
it's a tribute to talia's fighting
spirit that she kept playing on but you
know like I mentioned earlier in the
game I thought she was taking some risks
here because her pieces didn't
coordinate super well and white had
squares in this game and but again you
know if you want to get ahead in the
Chess World you have to fight and she
she did that and unfortunately for her
she paid a price for that fighting
Spirit today
that is a Pity that's
that was
well a nice comeback for foreign
let's see some of the other games that
we had here I thought Maria malishka or
Malika she Drew with Dennis
it looks like
I haven't drawn oh no no no no oh that
game no I was looking at another one
um so that came we stopped somewhere
around here where we thought black was
much better
so how did they end up drawing
so he didn't put enough pressure on
those those weaknesses over here right
right this is the game we're looking at
where black was better by a point and a
half so he won the spawn but gave up B7
was it necessary to give up that pawn B5
wasn't an option
oh he sacked a piece
wait where on the next move Rook takes
E3 and then he took on G3 oh wow okay
all right no I was I was just thinking
um this move first because that's still
a weakness that's not the real one
but okay uh he chose to make that did he
think that he had a win here Bishop
takes F3 Rook takes
and
well
okay this would be definitely good for
black that he just needs to make some
air and then that's hanging this Rook is
coming into play so Queen E7
so she played
oh nice come back with the queen
what
oh Rooker 5 is not possible because of
G4 yeah that's probably what he missed
when he went into this whole variation
this online so now he has to go for Rook
takes A3 in order to try so he
sacrificed the queen so he has two Rooks
for a queen and a bishop
but
okay G6 that makes sense yeah
so he must have missed this this move
this beautiful backward vision is very
important for a chess player
um that is there is a theme that
um
uh very uh very famous Grandmaster
Maurice Ashley has in his course on
trustable
secrets of Chess geometry he talks about
that quite a lot so Queen goes back to
E2 and now
yeah what a defense what about and you
cannot go Rook B3 that's the problem
because back rank
so that game ended in a dream yeah I'm
interested in the computer evaluation is
B5 there just real quick uh of B5 here
yeah
yeah that's minus one point it's minus
two essentially at black plays B5 oh it
said that this was the best move but not
giving up the bishop
so this was the blunder
a rook takes first
oh I see the difference is that now you
don't have queenies you have a bishop
because you have a bishop that's
threatening the mate
oh just a small move order can change
the entire thing
another very famous theme
well that's very unfortunate for Dennis
because he looked like he played a very
good game he played a very good game
here but but B5 was definitely
um make it more well I guess routes
or Bishop D6
okay well
so we want to go back to board one
lots of changes in this position looks
like in the end Darius ended up giving
up his Bishop for that annoying 19 F6 in
order to free his King but has he really
freed his King
at least now white doesn't have a
majority so that's one thing he's been
able to
do here but the bishop Perry is gonna be
so annoying to deal come on Bishop G5
not pontify
I think white is trying to keep the
squeeze on there
he's trying to find a way to take there
at some point possibly
yeah I think it's just a matter of you
want to keep the black king in a cage
and if you allow the exchange of Pawns
that the black king might get out of the
cage
[Music]
no no I didn't want to trade there I
want to go G5
no no I understand but I'm just saying
that when the night moves that you're
going to have the bishop to be able to
hit the F5 part so maybe maybe he wanted
this because in case of a trade he's
considering maybe taking you the pond
yeah we're taking him with the pawn and
everything is still caged in there but
and maybe he will have this kind of
option but I'm a little surprised though
but black would never want to take
because if they take right that's what I
say you can just let it sit there
Black's never going to want to take
that's but but I I'm a little surprised
white didn't go for a queen trade in
this position Queen E2 yeah with Queen
E2 and I'm not certain that it's winning
but if let's say black trades you know
my plan is just to you know King d2c3 V4
A5 B6
and yeah sure black can put his Knight
on D7 okay so now you've blocked all of
your pieces in for the rest of the game
and now I got to see if I can um
where's black gonna put this Knight on
D7 to keep my king out
but is he gonna take a note I don't
think you can take
because we take her the bishop I think
right or do we take still with the pawn
and now I I guess the question is is
that an absolute blockade
um
I mean Black's going to be limited to
moving his King back and forth
how far can he go he cannot yeah
right he's got to stay in the cage okay
so okay he's gonna stay there fine
okay then he's gonna stay with the
bishop right yeah and black can move
back and forth forever but we have this
we we have that in some lines is that
good here
Maybe
who's better I think I'm winning
oh my God this is a blockade
no uh wait can we no you can't give that
pawn up his Knight takes no no but but
uh
I have to play there so I will play here
and I'll play oops then I'll play there
yeah I thought it was a blockade it
might be it might be a draw This Night
comes out right
let's let's just show this line I think
it's so pretty
I think it's really pretty
um
can white win this position
I'll take you he cannot read this
position this is
yeah I think you're right you can't win
the position okay I I definitely could
have taken in G6 at some points but
right but but I I just thought and you
know that the heads
yeah it's probably a blockade oh okay I
this is a study like position if someone
says this
thing where you can play King B6 instead
of King takes B5 maybe I I'm not sure
well this is a pond that black intake at
some point which are kind of let it slip
right a little bit which I should have
considered but I mean that's certainly
when you have so little amount of time
you don't have time to evaluate all that
so if you're trying to play for a win
um you know you might want to keep the
question you're right right keeping the
Queens on the board is probably more
until you try to figure out whether he
can win or not and just make some moves
but give yourself some extra time but
they are not really beginning time right
but also the black queen has squares it
does it does have you know because
White's pushed everything forward so
when you push stuff forward you leave
space behind that the Queens can occupy
right but now wait he's covered this
diagonal he's covered these squares so
you cannot do anything there this is the
only way you can enter with the queen
and he hasn't tried that just yet so
maybe now okay so he moved the bishop
over but now that leaves this one weak
so
um but he doesn't want to push G5
because there's there's going to be a
capture and then one of those squares
will be free for the night so white is
white is going to have to okay now they
repeated the position I don't know black
has to be careful about figuring out
where these pieces have been and how
many times because
you know if you get a the position three
times and you miss the opportunity to
claim a draw you won't have it anymore
you can't claim after you've made a move
so you better get it right the first
time
actually I I don't know if I ever seen
this but if it doesn't have yeah I think
if you claim it wrong and then you claim
it correctly I don't even know if it
counts anymore
yeah I I don't really know what the rule
is to be quite honest
but okay why does changing things a
little bit here so
yeah it's not an easy position to to win
and with so little time on the clock
you know this is one of these positions
where you have to use what's called
schematic thinking and schematic
thinking is where do I put the pieces as
opposed to the specific tactics I agree
and with very little time on the clock
it's hard to figure out exactly where
they go
but it's an interesting position it's a
very interesting position and we'll have
to stay with this game uh we can
announce that there was a draw in this
game they were looking at earlier let's
see how they got to that draw so Bishop
G2 explained why is just waiting
black Advance with the H1 and finally
White had to give that pawn up and they
both went for a queen but now
there's no way for white to win this and
the players agreed on a draw okay
got one right that's good
um this position I think
we just didn't get the result there yeah
that has to be over it's kind of funny
that for that specific game Aaron's game
against Dahlia we had the result really
early on and then it disappeared now
that the result should be there it
doesn't want to go back right it happens
sometimes because Sada Perez's game
they're in a rook and pawn ending here
and this has been an interesting game
and it looks like
how did this
it looks like white could lose this game
now black
went on with that a pawn that we said
should not have been allowed okay so
okay so they traded Bishops and now
what is going on in this position
yeah I guess this is probably stupid
this is a drug because if you end up on
and you bring in the king here you'll be
fine but you need to get it there and
you need to get this spawn first
um will they be able to get I think
white can just play Rook A5 yeah that's
the only shot into Shuffle
yeah because yeah this
well you Black's gonna get an F6
you will yes so Rook A5 rookie six Rook
A7 I mean this is pretty much forcing uh
King G7 oh sorry
[Music]
um
King here King juice I think I want to
put my Rook on A7
oh I'm sorry you don't play King E3 King
E3 is fine yeah sure
um
okay
you have to I have to take down peso
black is gonna play right right I I
wanted to put the Rook on A7 just
interesting but it is but yeah but the
thing is if I still have that move and
then in that case
um you still have to take on passan I
think yep and then I'll take with the
rook and you still might need to go back
there unless you're attempting this but
if you go King C4 I think I'm going to
you cut you've cut me off you can't put
the King on C4 so yeah so that would be
quite bad because that's a jupon which
is going to be winning
so okay so you would have to come back
here and I have to go back there and
then we get the same position and then
we get the same kind of idea so the
question is can black find a way to
improve this position which
actually the king may go through here so
that if you go King G4 which you
probably have to play
um
it's going to be hard for black people
yeah I think this is a draw
I mean I mean you have the blockade
square and you're tied down to a weak
Pawn on E5 so well you're getting to
then I then I will have some chances but
actually the problem is the pro like you
know because I have this idea but but
luckily you have that check so if I stay
hidden there then
um you would just take my Pawn directly
so I couldn't move my Rook off the
e-file so yeah I guess I guess it will
it will be a draw but but he he went for
this move oh my goodness oh my goodness
this actually happened oh this actually
happened and black black is gonna win
this game after being a pawn up
um yeah you know it's amazing I mean
maybe maybe he still has some chances
but he's gonna be very tough you need to
bring the Rook back there no it's not
gonna help you it's not gonna help you
yeah it's amazing how many strong
players and again I've been guilty too
not that I'm in these guys class
not studying the rook and pawn endings
and and one of the biggest issues is
either having your king cut or a more
active King from another player he may
he may somehow still be able to make a
draw he may still be able but he's not
I don't know
um
wait so I go here you go wait a second
maybe maybe it's still a draw but if he
doesn't bring his King back you can
forget the draw you can forget it
this is still gonna be a draw I think
because you cannot go King H4 and G5
because now I'm going back here and
let's see do we have time for our
activity of the rock activation of the
road I think you want to check yeah no
no no no check the King on it yeah
because now I've got I can't go here
because I look here
well you can go there but I'll come here
G5
check check here here here yeah
Kings Behind the pawn I need to get
activity
uh well there's an extra Pawn here which
can give black
people like that we need to usually keep
the rook in front of the pond to stop it
from pushing but here black gets to push
it
so I I think I think this is a big
problem
this is a very big problem for for white
so now if we do that white has to go for
this other pawn and just hope that
he is in time
Patrick's suggesting that you're the
real Pro here at the draw evaluation but
I think we're waffling here between a
draw and a win I'm not sure
um it's it's it's kind of tricky it's
kind of tricky this end game because you
know there's there's some chances but
um
yeah of course you can turn on the
because how many pieces but with no time
on the clock I mean especially once you
moved your king over to the C file he
brought it to D5 I cannot believe that's
the right approach
so what does he want to do rookie it and
now which check does he want to give so
okay wait maybe he somehow manages to
give this check yeah maybe you can just
keep checking
and this
okay maybe he's found some other defense
mechanism at the king there I would I
would expect the king back was this
forcing though
I think so
yeah
okay we are going to have an interview
with Aaron burbinski so why don't we go
to that yeah that's
straight out of his win against Talia
Cervantes Aaron you know obviously this
is a good win for you with the white
pieces obviously the best result you can
possibly get how are you feeling uh
pretty good thank you uh it wasn't
really expected I thought I might could
draw halfway through the game but yeah a
win is always nice I was hoping before
the game to win of course that was wide
and much higher rated but she's a tough
player so yeah Talia she's a little
tricky definitely
to take us through your game and uh show
the people of what you did sure okay so
I'd prepared
um this variation of the Sicilian and I
knew she was going to play natter she
had some games with E5
um but I figured she'd probably play
Sicilian because she's in good form this
tournament she Drew her first two games
against Grandmaster so she's probably
pretty ambitious and after the game we
were talking I think she wanted to beat
me so yeah scary planned for a win so I
got 93 and I figured okay here she can
go 906 or A6 because she's a night or
player
yeah I saw okay six fine I'm 906 I had
something else in mind and then we got
this variation where yeah Queen D2 oh
interesting there's analysis Eros yeah I
could play Queen to two and B3 I guess
but my idea was Queen D3 and after
906.95 and uh my friend actually
um uh recommended this as an option When
I Was preparing last night and he was
like yeah okay if E6 takes takes and you
have C3 and now Bishop C5 is coming so
maybe H6 and then you go Bishop E3 and Y
to slide the better and you can't and I
was like what about Bishop E7 and then
Bishop B7 I was like oh but Bishop G5
and you take on E7 and it's no good
because D6 is weak of course but she
goes eventually seven
at this point I was like wait what and I
was like oh but this isn't even a good
move because 95 and I'm what am I doing
oh that's actually really interesting
yeah and I saw 95 and I'm like thanks a
lot
thanks bro yeah so I mean it's not bad
but like his recommendation wasn't
really what I thought it would be so
that was a nice surprise earlier a good
way to start the day
because now I think my best option is
probably to take the night and go Knight
C4 but after Queen C5 I'm probably just
worse
uh this wasn't very
very appetizing so I didn't go fish B5 I
just switched it up played Bishop E2
which okay now I'm out of prep and my
position is fine but there's nothing
special she's of course fine here
because she played this really good move
Queen G6 and E5 was a really good
combination for her um because now I
realized yeah okay she wants to Castle
go F5 and her counter plays pretty quick
she has her Knight of Pawn structure
probably she's very comfortable here
and I'm not sure what my plan should be
because yeah it's pretty tough to find a
plan she just wants to Bishop B6 or just
F5 so I go 92 yeah that makes sense
positionally but she goes to five
and here I thought she might go F4 and
trying to make me
um yeah throwing everything all the
Bishops yeah but I thought okay I'm
Knights 496 uh some counter play in the
middle D6 B3 but straight three yeah
anyway she castles and I was happy to
see this because now I take on F5 and
um I thought okay now maybe I can go to
Central grip with with the D5 and E4
squares positional bind let's say so
that's something so I was kind of happy
here until she played Queen H5 and I
realized Bishop H4 Rook F6 she's gonna
try to maybe yeah so I'm like oh my God
he's coming yeah she's coming the bishop
on D5 is really pretty but her pieces
are gonna try and hurt me so I wasn't
really sure what to do here play Knight
C4 if Bishop H4 have Bishop F3 that's
important oh yeah actually uh if I trade
the Queens I'm pretty happy there so Mr
Page four doesn't really work so she
goes back up six very ambitious move uh
I thought for a bit here she wants for
G6 I guess
so I played or even just double but it's
kind of scary My Queen on G3 is unstable
so I go here to offering a trade and at
this stage of the game yeah Queen E2
Queen E3 Queen H5 and I was like maybe I
should just make a draw so I go Queen G5
and I wasn't 100 committed to taking the
threefold because I was expecting the
score sheet I knew it hadn't been like I
hadn't locked it in yet yeah if she
wanted it I hadn't committed that
because it was only two so far but I was
like yeah my position is not that good
like if she goes Queenie too
again then
I'd probably go Queen E3 Queen H5 and
then I maybe make another move but it's
not so easy because I was thinking here
I can go Queen B6 but Queen B6 is she
probably has Bishop D3
[Music]
and yeah I just didn't like this stuff I
don't know that seemed pretty scary so
but she goes Queen E8 and I was smiling
internally because I was like oh okay
she wants to win she's she's trying a
game here so I'm like okay fine Queen G3
and I thought
yeah my plan is what was my plan I think
I wanted to go 93 or something
um and if Rook G6 I have she played
rookie six
um but she could have also forced me to
make a decision if she goes Queen H5 if
I go Queen G5 it's a draw but if I don't
win G5 then I have to play some probably
bad move and maybe lose I don't know if
I don't want the draw but okay she goes
56 and this helps me because she played
very directly but I don't think this was
so great for her because now my queen
gets a very good score on D3
and her Queen is only eight now so uh
her attacking potentials seriously
diminished the queen covers the the
third rank so there's page three is
nothing Rook d8 F3 and the nice trick
because yeah she kind of fell for it she
played description I have F4 now the
bishop regains yeah that's so spicy yeah
so she has to go all the back and now of
course the white should be much better
because all her pieces yeah retreating
Queen azania now I have good
coordination every piece makes sense now
for me crazy how that works yeah yeah
it's like just a few moves everything
yeah flipped but Bishop E3 I think this
may be a mistake because I gave her a
chance to kind of get back in some
activity because right now it looks very
depressing for her like it doesn't look
nice at all like yeah so I thought okay
just me three I need to finish
development but I should have done maybe
Knight B6 or something else because now
she goes B5 and I was like um yeah B5 is
a good move because now when I move the
Knight I have to she takes on F4 and she
gets 95. and once you put that oh yeah
that's a nice night yeah that night is
very annoying I can't really take it
without giving up something and if I
don't take it yeah that night's very
good piece I have a slight advantage in
terms of Pawn structure but that's about
it it's not a lot so I'm like okay we
need to division before Queen E3 I was
hoping for Bishop G4 because now when I
put the queen here there's no 9 G4 so
the queen is a little more stable and
queen D7 but I mean at this stage yeah
we have a lot of pieces so it's still a
full game but my main Hope was she was
getting well on time
she had under 10 minutes or something
around here maybe yeah 10 minutes and I
had 27 so that was the main advantage I
had like on the clock still playing for
some time yeah I mean the position I
have is good but I don't think she's
really that much worse so Bishop B4 Rook
F6 H3 yeah and here she could play
Bishop E6 but she goes straight five
okay but I think Bishop V6 was better
because now I go Bishop D5 and I put the
bishop back there so 94 yeah 94 is
coming he's coming a bishop on H5 is
just kind of off the side so it should
be for G6 good move 94. I thought she
should maybe take the Knight then I have
two Bishops which is something slightly
better Pawn structure and go A4 later uh
squeeze and end game maybe and she's a
long time so I thought okay very
comfortable but she goes here
and I was like okay fine I Rook D1
hinting at something I don't think it
works right away at all but the queen is
online with the Rook so it makes sense
yeah yeah uh Queen C7 I expected that
but now I have Knight G5 and I forced
her to give up yeah that's that's sad
for the bishop yeah so she has to give
me this which I was initially pretty
happy about but after and takes I think
might be a mistake I think she shouldn't
give up the f file I think she should
just move her Rook like Rook D E8 here
because the file is pretty important I
thought so I'm not sure why she just
preemptively gave it up like this
because now okay I have the f file and
it seemed pretty good her Knight can't
really move because there's Queen Aid
and Rook fade mate so I thought okay
King H1 and here I thought maybe she'd
play Queen C5 but she goes Bishop D3
which is probably a mistake because of
what she missed in the next move but
Queen C5 here was interesting
I can trade queens and go Bishop E7
taking advantage of the background
threats and the C5 Pawn is loose after
two Bishops
some pressure it should yeah there
should be seven feels good there yeah
yeah it should be nice but okay I'm not
sure if it was enough to win but she
goes Bishop D3 which I'm pretty sure is
a mistake because I have Rook of seven
she missed this she thought she could
take with the queen but she forgot
somehow her Knight is blocking the Rook
I'm not sure but basically she can't
take the Rook here so she definitely
missed that but here I was thinking
maybe she goes Queen C5 but then I play
Queen takes E5 dc5 Rook C7 oh and I
should be seriously better there if she
played C4 I can go Bishop D3 Bishop D4
and the Bishops are monsters my king is
much safer than yeah the queen side
pawns I just start harassing them at the
back rank it should collapse so she goes
to Queen C8 and
um yeah here I had a nice tactical idea
it turns out um which thankfully I saw I
almost played rookie seven but okay Rook
67 Bishop takes E7 Queen C7 and she's
probably holding that I could go Rook at
four but that also didn't make too much
sense uh I'm not sure she could repeat
the bishop or something but and then I
realized oh wait okay Rook takes G7
might be an option and I only saw this
because I ended up realizing after
Bishop H6 check she can't go to f626
it's kind of random how I stumbled
across it because I was gonna move the
road somewhere else I also saw Rook A7
but then she has Knight C6 and I might
lose so you're just you just found it by
process of elimination yeah I mean I was
looking at all my moves and then it just
happened to come into my brain so I was
like oh well okay it feels good yeah let
me think about it so actually yeah road
to xb7 she has to take the Rook night
night if the Knight moves I'm gonna have
I should have something pretty nasty for
example Knight G6 let's say
or Knight G4 okay let's say an ig4 for
example if she doesn't take the Rook she
can play 9g4 but and that's tricky
because you might think whoa okay my
queen is attacked twice rookie one might
be a back rank mate for me
my Rook on G7 is still hanging so Knight
G4 is definitely a spanner in the works
but I'm pretty sure after Knight G4 I
can just go rookie seven and if Knight
takes E3 Bishop F6 is mate
oh yeah that's pretty cool and the queen
D4 it's lost after rookie seven are
King's toes to the Bishops just yeah
start to kill her so yeah she has to
take the rook and then Bishop H6 of King
F6 G6 Queen G5 is made they're King
shade is fourth and I had to double
check this brows like okay there's no
way she defends G7 and F6 that has to be
made and then yeah there's no way her
Queen would have to get to E7 that'd be
the only defense and if she could get
her Queen to E7 she would win the game
but because Queen F6 is made and so it's
Queen G7 and Bishop G7 she resigned here
so man sadly that the queen can't move
like the Knight right yeah it's a shame
for me
interesting game
um I think she played pretty well just
missed some things at certain points uh
her time management like a little better
but I mean all of our time managements
could be a little bit better I mean yeah
so that's gonna put you on two points
now uh you're gonna be going into the
next round the black piece is most
likely yeah and probably against someone
strong someone really strong someone
very strong
that doesn't sound like you're so happy
about it it's good but uh I get black
again I had black last night against
antiplove and I think I had a good
opening but uh yeah he just outplayed me
so I hope that doesn't happen again
tonight that would be very depressing
well we wish you the best of luck here
thank you for coming on man I appreciate
it thank you very much
thank you very much Jacob for bringing
in that interview and a very nice
game by Aaron rabinski I really enjoyed
his taking us through the game
um and congratulations for the win I it
was kind of
exciting to hear that he was he stumbled
across that Rook takes G7 move and I can
show it here for for the audience
um
in this position after Rook F7 he was
unsure to go with the Rook if you guys
missed that interview when he was saying
um yeah so I realized I couldn't go
rookie seven because she's withhold that
end game after the trade rookest A7
maybe Knight C6 and I'm in trouble so
then I stumbled across this move I'm PR
maybe he just said it for for the
audience or maybe that's how it worked
but process of elimination is a nice
technique to get to the right here I I
think it was a nice interview and I
think there is a process to finding the
moves and you know there's sort of this
you know check capture threat you know
process that you should go through here
and you made an aggressive move with the
Rook all the pieces are pointed at the
king side so there's also this concept
that when the pieces are ready and you
can't improve anymore
your opportunity is right then and there
if you let it slip you you may let the
the game slip away that's right and I
think you know to Aaron's point there
any other move and he's not better yeah
yeah so you have to find the right one
um I I was watching
um I was going over some courses on
Chesterville and Judith poger has this
thing that you call CCTV
um it's like checks captures threats and
variations that you have to take under
consideration in order to be able to get
to the right move in each position but
this game is about to be over which it
was a crazy game of scene
um and it's the final game left there
was a result in that game
um a draw finally in that game they were
looking earlier between dudin and
quesada Perez so we've seen
we've seen the position until here and
then they went they just made the trades
and the game ended in a draw so
yeah looks like Darius has resigned in
the end in that game we can just replay
the final moves because it was such a
gorgeous final I think we're discussing
the possibility of white trading the
queens and getting into that end game
that possibly could have been a draw at
least we found some beautiful line that
led into a draw despite having a pawn
and a bishop up or something like that
but
um looks like Nicolas teodoro was able
to find some other way so he's blocked
the e-files strengthened the bishop
there so that no ideas for Knight D7
could allow Black's Queen to get active
and then he came with the queen on the a
file this really is definitely
reminiscent of that capablanca tree ball
game that I always like to mention for
some reason it's one of my favorites
from that that point of view that your
opponent has nothing to do and you just
get to just
improve every single move so he doesn't
trade Queens even here
and finally
he takes that night it's crazy to
believe that this is the best move in
the position when you give up a bishop
for the night that wasn't doing anything
for the past 20 moves or something but
this is where you get to sacrifice all
of your pieces to crack through and you
know Queenie AIDS capitulation so we
should at least show the variation if
black takes with the F Pawn after King
takes f8 I'm sorry
okay I mean Queenie nature just losing
the game so presumably here you play
Bishop takes H takes an H7 and it's just
over and you have no way to stop each
from promoting and this is the whole
Lila concept here is that even though H6
closes files that the what the king is
sort of crowded out in a danger for the
long term and and here we are it moves
71 so we are
45 moves past where white plate age six
give or take
and yet it was just a slow build and you
know we were looking at the evaluation
in our various breaks and and white was
always significantly better yeah
and and here um G7 was the move that
that terradora decided to play uh
capturing here was the other option but
that would give black the opportunity to
have a Perpetual check at least if not
more here probably even more
Maybe
can I I don't know there's no points as
long as well black or white keeps his
King on the blood dark squares I I don't
see that there's
but maybe we start with that pawn yeah
you get them all and then then maybe we
don't we don't get the CH I mean I don't
think we can take because our Bishop is
singing but we do have Perpetual at
least sure I think
so there's there's no reason to get into
this position there's no reason so G7
check he played and then he brought in
the king it's kind of funny we're
looking in the as we're um watching the
interview as well at Queen C7 and the
idea is that we are actually giving up
the bishop take that bishop and now
there's gonna be a Checkmate so
um you know you only have one check
unfortunately with black and you still
have this Pawn so black can never think
of any kind of stalemate in this
position unfortunately because that pawn
will always be able to move it's really
a gorgeous game and I feel for Darius
for
um having to having had to struggle in
this game
and he tried to activate his Queen but
this bishop somehow together with the
queen they're powerful enough that they
keep most of Black's checks so even if
Darius was able to get that g pawn and
give a few more checks in the end there
is nothing left King B3 and now
um the idea once again this idea of
sacrificing the queen to get a stalemate
never really works because that pawn
although blocks right now is never going
to be captured you can't if you
sacrifice the queen here we won't make
this blunder
to stalemate we will capture the king
and
and we moved the king somewhere and then
there's gonna be a mate but he did try
and sacrifice the queen yes oh he did he
did try to go Queenie too yeah
um so obviously if you take it now
that's a stalemate so you can't do that
he also keeps his Bishop protected so he
can't take it but but their daughter had
this nice move Bishop takes H7 check and
after King takes he promoted which
allowed his other Queen to come into
play with check the next move followed
by Queen G7 made so in this position
black resigned if he had taken here
um and how many moves do we find the
mate and I only see one in two maybe
hopefully I'm not missing one in one
that would be that would be bad but here
and here and
that's a fantastic game and
um we're going to take a look look at
the results for round three
what a game what a day it was we had
some good Fighting Chess here um on
board one we had ilionic with a draw
against Brian and that was the game
where um White had the two connected
past pawns and black had the split Pawns
in the end games that was a very
interesting game Darius is really a
world-class player so for Nicholas that
is a a very impressive win the the Fidel
Corrales game with Iran was a fantastic
fighting game with the Deep opening
preparation the F3 nimso Indian uh the
Casada game it looked like an
opportunity for I am club dude in there
but unfortunately he wasn't able to
convert corrosion if you recall that
game ended very early that was an
exchange slot that turned into a very
sharp tactical fight and and Barr took a
draw and elshon and Christopher you they
played a very correct closed Catalan if
that's a fair way to put that then it
ended in a draw and Brandon Jacobson he
played a nice win against costume where
he had the rosalimo Sicilian with Bishop
takes C6 and he did a wonderful job of
explaining you know where the black
pieces needed to be to defend his attack
and when you know costume really made
two what appeared to be relatively small
positional heirs and Brandon just rolled
over him after that and then we saw the
game with Dennis boros and and I can't
remember if we showed it on the
broadcast where Dennis sacked a piece on
G3 Edition and he took unfortunately
with his Rook on F or Bishop on F3 when
actually Rook takes up three would have
been a winning position for him so it
was a move transposition that ended up
throwing a win away for Dennis which is
very unfortunate for him
and and Aaron you know he just had an
interview where he showed us very nicely
how he won that game
and I don't think we spend a lot of time
at Josiah's game at all today and we I
know we didn't look at Irene's game
all right let's see the last uh last
results there Caleb Denby Drew against
Evan Park obviously won her game against
round 10 Aaron Jacobson so the brother
of
Brendan won against Linda Lee and Sila
chaglar won against Nicolas ladan or
Nicholas has gotten a couple of tough
losses Gabriela antova won her game
against Julian perlacco and you we
already let you know about the buys they
were taken in this round so very
exciting chess it was great you know
going over all these games with you I
was very much impressed about everything
I gotta say I love the attacking games
but I also love this kind of positional
position on games where someone just
definitely outplace the other person
where they don't have much to play those
are I think the most beautiful for me
but hopefully the audience has enjoyed
our commentary
um very excited for tomorrow
while today there's another round that
is going to be played at 5 p.m so in
about an hour around four of the super
Swiss starts we are not going to go over
that game and we will be back tomorrow
at 11 20 a.m central time for commentary
of round five
you can always replay these videos both
on Twitch and YouTube on sellers chess
clubs page feel free to tweet us we'll
try our best to respond to all of your
questions and we wish you a wonderful
arrest of your day and looking forward
to seeing you tomorrow
at 8 20 a.m Central Time yes
sitting there going holy cow I only have
to get up early tomorrow morning you're
scary I had to mess something up all
right we'll see you tomorrow guys thank
you
[Music]
foreign
chess club's 2023 chess season launches
in March for the second annual American
Cup world-class Chess Masters will
gather in the chess capital of America
St Louis Missouri to compete in a double
elimination tournament for a combined
three hundred thousand dollars in prizes
we will cover all the action live from
the World Chess Hall of Fame from March
17th through March 26th tune in for the
best game in chess streaming live for
more information visit uschesschamps.com
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited